Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Samalinos, wer zur Hölle bist du eigentlich und wer zahlt dich.
Ich bin der Geist, der stets verneint und das mit Recht. Denn alles, was entsteht, ist wert, das ist zu Grunde geht,
Drum besser wär's, dass nichts entstünde, so ist denn alles, was ihr Sünde, Zerstörung, kurz das Böse nennt, mein eigentliches Element.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, die äh,
Na, hundertachtundsechzigste Ausgabe und wir haben gerade alle meine Sendung, mehr oder weniger dieselbe Nummer, komme ich ganz durcheinander. Ähm aber jetzt bin ich mir doch sicher.
Ist es tatsächlich so?
Ja, gammelt auch gerade so in diesem Bereich rum und so.
Hundertneunundsechzig war die letzte Freakshow Episode.
Das muss sich jetzt alles erstmal wieder so ein bisschen auseinander entwickeln. Aber ich halte mich wacker. Ja ähm.
Live aus den äh Kultur und Tiefen Deutschlands berichten wir und ähm nachdem wir jetzt,
diverse äh Spezialsendungen gemacht haben. Können wir jetzt langsam mal wieder so ein bisschen zu unserem Standardformat übergehen.
Wir haben doch schon wieder einen Spezial.
Ja, ich wollte das auch gerade ein bisschen einschränken. Andererseits äh sieht's auch gerade so aus, als ob wir äh
Und auch in den nächsten äh äh Sendungen mit äh erhöhter Gästebeteiligung arbeiten und begrüßen heute den John. Jolef Nebel,
Moin.
Ist ein äh Berliner Blogger und du betreibst, glaube ich, seit einiger Zeit diese Webseite ähm Metronaut.
Äh ja genau, ich ich blogge bei Metronaut, äh schon weil Metronaut gab's schon irgendwie um die Jahrtausendwende damals noch als Berliner Stadtmagazin und ist dann kurzzeitig mal irgendwann eingeschlafen und dann äh zweitausendfünf oder sechs
äh als Block wieder auferstanden
und wir beschäftigen uns also gibt da einige Leute die da bloggen beschäftigen uns mit sozialen Bewegungen, Bürgerrechte aller Art, also nicht nur diese Einschränkung auf digitale
Bürgerrechte, die ich sowieso äh schwierig finde, äh aber auch mit Kommunikationsguerrilla, PR, Medien, ähm,
Ja, Protest so im weitesten Sinne.
Bloggen denn da?
Mal zwei, mal drei, mal fünf. Also es gibt so einige Leute und ich äh ja, mache da, bin da am längsten mit dabei, aber so ist schon mehr Autorenblock.
Mhm. Und es gibt auch einen Podcast.
Und es gibt natürlich auch einen Podcast, Metrolaut, genau. Der sehr unregelmäßig und selten rauskommt, aber Spaß macht.
So ist das bei Podcast. Ich meine, ist ja auch immer besser. Man sagt was, wenn man was zu sagen hat als,
dass man da so zwanghaft äh unterwegs ist. Und auch mit Rolla ist ja jetzt nicht so wie Netzpolitik, Org, wo so äh jeden Tag fünf Nachrichten und mehr äh runterrasseln, sondern auch das ist immer so, es gibt mal wieder was zu sagen.
Ja, also.
Darstellen wollen.
Nee, MetroDau, das ist schon ein klassisches äh Feierabendblock, was irgendwie ja, also ich ich schreibe da, wenn mich irgendwas irgendwie bewegt, aufregt oder wenn irgendwas reinkommt, was irgendwie spannend ist. Ja,
also.
Also ein Feierabendblock mit Laber Podcast. Gibt's ja auch noch.
Best of Both Worlds.
Na ja, ich würde es nicht sagen, der Laber-Podcast ist klingt so anstrengend, so zwei Leute, die sich kennen, die die ganze Zeit labern. Also das wird eher als so eine Art äh Interview-Podcast äh äh,
sehen, aber auch mit Experimentier, Freude, also.
Ja, wir hatten das ja hier auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, da gab's ja dann irgendwie äh diese besonderen Sendungen da direkt vom Gesi von den Gesidemonstrationen und so, das äh ist weit äh entfernt von äh Laber Podcast-Style,
ansonsten sage ich auch mal und wenn schon, ja? Also all helde Lava Podcast, das äh ist ja auch eine Qualität.
Ja, ich glaube, diese Folge mit denen, wo ihr irgendwie mit den Dschihadisten euch da auseinandergesetzt habt, die war die letzte, ne? Das war ja schon.
Genau, das das war die letzte und ich meine das Grundprinzip, also von da so normalen Folge, wenn wir uns da nicht gerade im Gesipark die äh Tränengasgranaten um die Ohren schießen lassen
ist eigentlich so, dass wir bekochen den Gast äh und machen dann,
leckeren Getränken äh weiter und reden einfach, ne? Und versuchen da möglichst äh interessante Leute ranzubringen, die was Schönes zu erzählen haben und auch tief in Thema rein, wie das so eben
ist also Interview-Podcast.
Mit kochen, ne, da muss ich ja mal gucken, ob ich wenn ich vielleicht auch mal hinkommen könnte oder so. Vielleicht habe ich ja meine interessantes Thema.
Gabe ihr Podcast hat ja eh schon die ganze.
Ja, ja, stimmt. Schade.
Ich kann ja unter Pseudonym auftreten.
Wäre eine Idee, ne?
Aber also ein Artikel von dir war auch der Grund, warum wir dich äh eingeladen haben in die heutige Sendung. Du hast dich nämlich glaube ich als,
Wahrscheinlich als erster mit der Mainzer Erklärung auseinandergesetzt.
Ähm kann man nicht.
Vielleicht gab's auch andere Blogs, die jetzt noch früher aufgegriffen haben.
Also du meinst ja, die ersten, die sich auseinandergesetzt haben, waren durchaus Zeitungen, weil diese Mainzer Erklärung der CDU, die ist
vorab geleakt worden in der Vorversion
und äh die wurde im Rahmen dieser Berichterstattung um die äh um Köln, ne, um Hauptbahnhof Köln äh wurde da, was die CDU plant an Maßnahmen äh,
eigentlich beleuchtet und was
ich gemacht hatte, war so mal gucken, was bedeuten eigentlich diese diese Maßnahmen, die die CDU fordert und die durchaus auch wahrscheinlich in der SPD teilweise äh Anhänger finden, äh wie wie die sich auf äh Grund- und Bürgerrechte
auswerten. Und ich glaube, da war das schon der erste Artikel, der dass man den Fokus auf diese auf die Fragen gesetzt hat.
Also wir haben irgendwie was ist überhaupt, warum haben die jetzt, es gab hier erst im Dezember schon eine Karlsruhe Erklärung von dem
Bundesparteitag, was war jetzt in Mainz? Warum haben die, warum haben die da jetzt auf einmal eine Mainzer Erklärung da, also.
Die machen, glaube ich, wenn die so eine Klausurtagung machen, dann hauen die dann so eine Erklärung raus, die dann die Stadt vorne dran gibt. Gibt's wahrscheinlich noch zig andere Erklärungen, die sie gemacht haben und äh,
Wahrscheinlich hätten sie diese Klausur auch ohne Köln gemacht, aber das haben sie natürlich dann irgendwie schön genutzt äh um verschiedene Dinge,
da zu fordern. Also ein Teil ging um eben Asyl und Ausländer Recht äh dann ähm die Leute schneller abschieben oder ausweisen zu können. Ähm,
und ich habe mich aber eigentlich gar nicht um so um diese Dinge äh gekümmert, sondern eher um Sachen, die einfach alle betreffen. Ähm,
Ja und das waren einerseits eben der Schutzparagraph hundertzwölf.
Also ich finde noch ganz
kurz, ich äh also weil du jetzt ja sagst, es gibt ja einen Teil dieser Mainzer Erklärung, den wir jetzt quasi nicht äh behandeln und äh ich habe dieses Dokument hier gerade vor mir, ist also der Beschluss des Bundesvorstands der CDU
anlässlich der Klausurtagung, wie du sagtest, am achten und neunten Januar in Mainz. Und was ich bei sowas ja immer ganz spannend finde, ist, das ist jetzt hier ein Dokument, was hat das vielleicht zwölf, fuffzehn, zwanzig Seiten oder so, ne? Elf ähm,
und auf dem Titelblatt steht ja dann immer so die steht ja so die Leitlinien und was jetzt offenbar zweitausendsechzehn die CDU beschäftigt ist Wettbewerbsfähigkeit,
Zusammenhalt und Sicherheit,
unser Zehn-Punkte-Zukunftsplan für Deutschland. Ich mein so, Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und Sicherheit dominieren irgendwie so, dass demokratische Geschehen seit mindestens zehn Jahren,
Zusammenhalt ist irgendwie ein Begriff, der mir,
in dem Zusammenhang zumindest nicht so geläufig ist wie wie Sicherheit und Wettbewerbsfähigkeit, aber damit also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, jetzt wisst ihr, wo es hingeht. Ja, für eine gute Zukunft Deutschlands,
brauchen wir äh Wettbewerbsfähigkeit, Zusammenhalt.
Zusammenhalt natürlich auch in in Abgrenzung zu Leuten, ne, wenn man da rein liest, das ist also wir müssen uns da alle zusammenhalten, aber ein andauerndes aktuellen Zuzugs wird die Staatengesellschaft,
auf Dauer überfordern, ne? Also es ist immer so Zusammenhalt, ja, wir, aber da andere nicht, ne? Aber okay, das ist halt CDU.
Ja. Ein starker Zusammenarbeit, Zusammenhalt, ja?
Okay, also da da genau, wir wissen, es ist eine Zeit, in der die äh der,
dem Zuzug Geflüchteter nach Deutschland irgendwie die die Gesellschaft beschäftigt und so auch die Parteien mit dem C und dem U,
Aber wir wollen uns jetzt hauptsächlich um die die Bürgerrechte,
unter über die Bürgerrechte unterhalten, die jetzt da abgesetzt werden. Und du hast gesagt, Paragraph einhundertzwölf Schutzparagraph einhundertzwölf. Was ist das?
Genau. Also,
Es gibt den Schutzparagraphen oder den Paragraphen Strafgesetzbuch hundertdreizehn, das ist Widerstand gegen Vollstreckungsbeamte. Das ist, wenn ich äh einem,
Polizisten oder auch äh Feuerwehrmann äh
während er im Einsatz ist, wenn ich da irgendwie Ärger mache, äh dann kann ich Widerstand gegen die Staatsgewalt, also wegen gegen Versteckungsbeamte bekommen. Das ist also ein zusätzliches also,
irgendjemand haut einem Polizisten aufs Maul, ähm
Man kriegt ja nicht nur eine Körperverletzung, sondern noch Widerstand mit dazu. Ne, oder ich will mich aus der Gefangenen befreien, äh wird Gefahr. Also da kriegt man äh recht schnell noch so ein, also ein Zusatzparagraph der Polizisten
mehr schützt äh als den Normalbürger bei,
Und was jetzt kommt, dieser Schutzparagraph hundertzwölf, der geht auf interessanterweise auf eine Initiative,
Also äh der der hessischen Landesregierung schwarz-grün,
ähm ist die, äh der geht darauf zurück, nach diesen, es gab doch im letzten Jahr Blockupe, Banken, europäischer Zentralbank Eröffnung, da gab's ja Ausschreitungen und so und dann haben die das gefordert. Und dieser Schutzparagraph hundertzwölf,
nochmal so ein Layer von äh Schutz auf äh auf äh Polizisten, um drauf, das heißt.
Es passiert jetzt irgendwas. Ich gerate in äh Rangelei hinein. Die Polizei wirft mir Körperverletzung vor. Ähm,
Ich kriege Widerstand gegen die Staatsgewalt, sagt sie auch. Und dann nochmal diesen Schutzparagraph hundertzwölf, weil ich eben Gewalt ausgeübt hätte gegen Polizisten,
Äh und das Interessante an diesem Schutzparagraph hundertzwölf ist, das wird gar nicht mit mit ähm,
äh mit Bewährung oder so, sondern es geht gleich mindestens sechs Monate Haft. Das heißt, das ist einfach nochmal ein einen äh eine äh eine zusätzliche Bestrafung, wenn man gegen Polizisten,
verurteilt wird.
Aber du hast so, also,
Prinzipiell ist das ja nichts, was du jetzt vorher durftest, ne. Also wenn du jetzt einen Polizisten angreifst, also der der es ist ja irgendwie,
Widerstand, genau, also Widerstand leisten, kriegst du schon einen aufn Sack, wenn du Menschen angreifst sowieso, natürlich
wenn du Polizisten angreifst, erst recht in der Regel kann ich aus leidlicher Erfahrung sagen, ist das sowieso das einzige, wo du wirklich was für auf den Sack kriegst? In der Regel so Körperverletzung gegenüber Zivilisten wird halt in der Regel,
doch nicht nennenswert verfolgt, weil es einfach viel zu viel davon gibt und ähm sich die Situation in der Regel nicht aufklären lassen, es sei denn, du hast ein
Polizisten dabei, der sagt, jo aua aua ähm,
der der hat mir weh getan, dann geht das natürlich relativ schnell. Und jetzt kriegst du quasi noch zu diesem zu dieser Situation,
Oben drauf kriegst du jetzt noch Schutzparagraph hundertzwölf ähm wo du.
Ey, also das dasadiert sich dann eben auf, ne, also du kriegst dann jetzt ein Jahr für die Körperverletzung, dann nochmal noch ein Jahr für den für Schutzparagraph hundertzwölf und Widerstand nach oben drauf, also du hast eine eine deutlich höhere Strafmaß, wenn da was passiert.
Äh das birgt halt grundsätzlich äh zwei Probleme. Einerseits hat man halt in einem Rechtsstaat,
so eine Gleichheitsgrundsatz, ne, dass alle Menschen eigentlich egal, ob ich jetzt dir, äh ob du, also jeder wird gleich dafür bestraft, egal, wer du bist, äh deswegen hat Justitia auch verbundene Augen, ne? Also äh,
Das soll nicht Leute bevorteilen und das gibt eben nochmal einen, also das verletzt den Gleichheitsgrundsatz äh auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite,
Und ich glaube, das ist ist auch sehr schwerwiegend, dass die so einen Schutzparagraph äh.
Eigentlich eine versteckte versteckte Einschränkung des Demonstrationsrecht ist, weil es eben Unsicherheiten auch bringt für den für den für Demonstrierende. Also das heißt, man,
wer mal auf einer äh Anti-Nazi-Demonstration war, weiß, wie schnell es auf einmal irgendwie Gerangel gibt, weil Leute in der Sitzblockade sind, dann kommt Polizei und ne, du kannst den sehr schnell in so eine Situation reingeraten
wo man dich zum Beispiel da anklagen könnte, das heißt,
Befürchtung ist aus Sicht der Grund- und Bürgerrechte, dass sich Leute dann eben auch weniger getrauen auf Demonstrationen zu gehen. Das Ganze ist natürlich bei sagen wir mal Aktionen, zivilen Ungehorsams noch gefährlicher und setzt da höhere Hürden.
Okay. Der hat also ja, ich denke mal, da wird man trotzdem in der ähm.
In der Bevölkerung irgendwie noch so ein Verständnis für haben, ne? Also ich,
Denke halt irgendwie, äh ja, also den den wirst du nicht abschießen können, ne? Da da kannst du halt irgendwie zu schön für argumentieren, ne? Also ja wie, das kann doch nicht sein, ne? Und die Polizisten sind doch für unseren Schutz da. Ähm.
Ich will, ich will, ich will jetzt gar nicht die die Polizei als Ganzes in in Frage stellen. Man muss halt nur sich die Entwicklung der letzten, wenn man sich die Entwicklung der letzten dreißig Jahre von Polizei,
also Bilder von Demonstrationen anschaut, hat man natürlich eine extreme Militarisierung. Kannst du da sehen? Das ist ja grundsätzlich schon mal ein Problem. Das schreckt ja auch dann,
Menschen auch ab auf eine Demonstration zu gehen, wenn da gleich irgendwie geschützt. Also das ist so eine eine Grundatmosphäre, die dem Demonstrationsrecht und der Demonstrationsfreiheit nicht,
nicht förderlich ist. Das hat man auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen ist es halt die Frage,
Also zumal eben auch ein Großteil der Fälle jetzt schon von Widerstand gegen die Staatsgewalt äh erfasst ist, da nochmal was oben drauf zu setzen. Also ist auf jeden Fall ähm,
schwierig. Dazu kommt eine Sache mit ähm wenn man Fälle von Polizeigewalt sich anschaut,
ist es ja oft so, dass es dagegen Anzeigen gibt, also das heißt, ich werde Opfer von Polizeigewalt zeige Beamte an
schon recht schlechte Chancen damit durchzukommen,
dass da jemand verurteilt wird, wie oft passiert's aber, dass die Polizei eben eine Gegenanzeige macht, die sagt, ah hier, aber nicht Widerstand gegen die Staatsgewalt gemacht und äh Körperverletzung und dann wird eben der Schutzparagraph noch obendrauf kommen. Das heißt, da,
wieder auch einen einen was hochgefahren, wo Leute sich dann auch nicht mehr trauen, weil es eben auch gleich mit Knast verbunden ist. Ähm.
Das ist auch ein klassisches äh Mittel, was man zum Beispiel in USA sehr oft findet, dass da eigentlich,
komplett ausgeliefert ist, weil eigentlich äh alles, was in irgendeiner Form, was man vorbringen könnte äh an im Mund herumgedreht wird und man findet sich dann sozusagen selber im Knast wieder, also da gibt's so viele Stories, bedrückend.
Ja und ich denke, dass diese, also dieser Schutzparagraph da eher zum, von einem schwarz-grünen Bündnis vorangetrieben wurde, ähm, im Bundesrat aber noch nicht durch ist. Äh, und da ist sicher eine Offenheit, jetzt hat die CDU in Berlin das auch gefordert und das wird also, ähm,
uns,
begleiten die Diskussionen darüber sind relativ sind wahrscheinlich nur in Bürgerrechtskreisen ist man da sehr vorsichtig weil es eben 'ne weitere Verschärfung ist und man.
Indirekt im das Demonstrationsrecht ein äh schränkt. Was dann noch in der Mainzer Erklärung ist, ist die Ausweitung der Schleierfahndung,
Ist ursprünglich mal eingeführt worden, damals auch unter großen Diskussionen, ob das äh
legal sein könnte und verfassungsgemäß, als man die Schengen, die Innengrenzen der EU aufgemacht hat, also keine Grenzhäuschen mehr und da war die Sache, ja, wir möchten im Zollgrenzbezirk, der ist äh, war damals, glaube ich, nur fünfzehn Kilometer, da möchten wir
anlasslos äh und verdachtsunabhängig kontrollieren, um eben so ein bisschen Ersatz zu schaffen für die
Grenzhäuschen, dann wurden die Zollgrenzzonen, glaube ich, ausgeweitet auf dreißig Kilometer, dann wurde es ausgeweitet auf äh gefährliche Orte und
und auf irgendwie äh in der Bahn und so und diese Schleierfahndung ähm äh,
ist ein durchaus umstrittenes äh Instrument, wenn man davon ausgeht, also die ursprüngliche,
ursprüngliche Gesetz sieht vor, ein Polizist darf die eigentlich nur behelligen, kontrollieren, wenn er einen Verdacht hat. Also ich habe irgendwie.
Begründeter Verdacht. Ich wurde gesehen, uh, der hat gerade im Laden geklaut, also darf den kontrollieren. Aber einfach so, weil irgendwie ich Dreadlocks habe oder irgendwie
in ein rassistisches Muster auch passe, ne? Also ich bin jetzt irgendwie bin Fahrzug und bin äh bin dunkelhäutig, dann gerate ich da eher rein und das ist eigentlich nicht erlaubt, ohne einen einen äh konkreten
Verdacht zu haben und Schleierfahndung macht es eben äh äh ja macht weicht das komplett auf und die CDU hat jetzt gefordert, dass man eben,
bei der Gefährdung der öffentlichen Sicherheit auch diese Schleierfahndung eben anwenden könnte dann an Silvester, Karneval, wann auch immer
sie eine Einschränkung oder Sicherheit sehen,
eben weiterhin ein weiteres rechtsstaatliches Prinzip und ein Bürgerrechtliches Prinzip eben aufweichen und Kontrollen überall erlauben oder deutlich mehr erlauben als bisher.
War das denn jemals ein Prinzip, dass man, dass man irgendwie geltend machen konnte? Also gibt es dokumentierte Fälle von Leuten, die gesagt haben, der Polizist durfte mich da gar nicht kontrollieren, weil äh.
Also in der polizeilichen Praxis ist es so gewesen, dass du also Situationen irgendwo, du bist außerhalb eines Schleierfahndungsgebietes, ein Polizist kommt auf dich zu und meist
ein großer Prozentsatz der Leute ist, wenn die kontrolliert werden, auch wenn das äh illegal ist, die kooperieren dann I.
Ich kann aber, wenn ich kontrolliert werde und merke so, hey, was wollen die eigentlich? Ich bin hier einfach nur mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs oder was weiß ich. Äh und sage, stopp mal, was haben sie denn für einen Verdacht, können sie denn benennen?
Und die haben keinen, dann hören die auf, ne? Also das ist äh durchaus natürlich eine
Sache. Die haben natürlich auch Tricks, wie sie sowas machen. Also wenn du Verkehrskontrollen sind erlaubt, ne? Und wie sie das dann machen, diese Anker zum Beispiel, zeigen sie mal ihr ihr äh äh Rettungskasten und und Wanderereck,
das ist immer so eine, das ist dann im äh hinten im Kofferraum und dadurch schaffe ich eine Durchsuchung über die Verkehrskontrolle
Also die hatten schon auch Tricks oder dass sie die Fragen könnten wir ihren Ausweis sehen. Ist ja keine Aufforderung, geben sie einen Ausweis. Und die Leute kooperieren dann.
Ist genauso, wenn die dich äh also es gibt viele so Sachen, wo die Formulierungen so sind, äh
Kontrolle machen auf auf Drogentest zum Beispiel dürfen sie nicht also ist freiwillig sagen aber ja machen wir hier können wir machen hier dringend wollen sie nicht mal pinkeln
Dann sagst du, nö, will ich nicht. Dann sagst du, ja, warum machen sie denn nicht mit, warum kooperieren sie denn nicht? Äh ja, muss das sagen, ist freiwillig.
Ja, aber also bei den, das ist ja eigentlich auch so eine Falle, in die viele Tappen ähm,
Klar kannst du bei, bei so einer allgemeinen Verkehrskontrolle
verweigern in dieses Röhrchen zu pusten. Aber genau das nehmen sie ja dann als Anhaltspunkt und Verdacht und so weiter um dich mit auf die Wache zu schleppen und deinen Arzt hinzubestellen, die dann Blut abnimmt. Also quasi,
Na, das habe ich schon oft genug so äh gehört und gesehen und erlebt, dass halt irgendwie klar, wenn jetzt wirklich völlig un also wenn du völlig unauffällig bist und irgendwie relativ
ziemlich klar ist, dass du jetzt irgendwie jemand bist, mit dem nicht zu ähm wo sie sich eventuell die Zähne ausbeißen, aber ich habe,
Also ich meine, ich habe im Bekanntenkreis keine besonders guten Erfahrungen damit, ähm sage ich mal, auch gegen nicht begründete,
nicht rechtmäßige Aufforderungen der Polizei Widerstand zu leisten, weil genau das dann eben als der ausschlaggebende Verdacht äh gewertet wird. Oder wurde.
Würde ich, also ich ich kenne andere Fälle, ähm wo Leute oder wo die Polizei Romberg-Test, da ging's Leute auf einem Festival gearbeitet, fahren da zurück, kommen in diese Kontrolle rein, äh,
haben sich einfach dagegen gewehrt. Meinte, nee, was sie hier machen wollen, ist jetzt illegaler Weise ein Rombergtest mit mit der Person. Das dürfen sie doch nicht, wissen sie doch und,
Da hat die Polizei immer gesagt, ja komm, äh ich meine, der hat wahrscheinlich auch gesehen, okay, die sind nüchtern.
Also äh wenn du da gut gerechtlich argumentieren kannst, zeigst du vielleicht auch, dass du nüchtern bist, äh aber es ist halt eben nicht so, dass man irgendwie einfach so Kontrollen machen darf. Ähm.
Das soll sich aber jetzt hier ziemlich klar ändern.
Mit äh also,
wenn erhebliche Gefahren für die öffentliche Sicherheit und Ordnung bestehen würden. Was ist da die Frage, was sind erhebliche Gefahren für die, also wann tritt es ein, aber dann wäre das eben nochmal eine Ausweitung von Schleierfahndungen.
Das zeigt halt eben auch schön, ne, du hast wieder also was in in den Bürgerrechte, Einschränkungen und Grundrechteabbau hat so ein ganz klassisches Muster, ist, ist das,
Dinge werden eingeführt. Es gibt dagegen Protest und Widerstand wie damals bei der Schleierfahndung und wenn's mal da ist, wird's sukzessive halt eben weiter ausgeweitet, zu Ungunsten äh äh der Menschen.
Und der rechtlichen Position von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern.
Und dann geht's auch noch schneller in den Knast.
Genau, also da die CDU fordert eben äh dass äh ein,
hinreichender Tatverdacht ausreichen soll, damit man in U-Haft kommen kann, bislang hat man einen dringenden Tatverdacht gebraucht, ähm ja. Das ist äh die Eins und dann gibt's noch weitere Punkte drin, die eben dann eher in den äh.
Also sich gegen Asylbewerbern äh richten, wo es eben darum geht, wenn jemand äh,
verurteilt wird auf ein Jahr, egal ob Bewährung äh oder Freiheitsstrafe, dann kann man ihn ausweisen,
Das war davor war das irgendwie zwei Jahre und ohne Bewährung und das ist jetzt halt halbiert worden. Ähm,
Das ist das eine und die anderen Forderungen und da bringt die CDU eben, also das sind eher dann wieder netzpolitische und digitale Bürgerrechte, bevor äh äh treffende äh Forderungen, die sind eben sowas wie Erweiterung von,
äh Europol, um europäisches Antiterrorzentrum oder Daten aus der Vorratsdatenspeicherung soll dem Verfassungsschutz zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Das ist ein das finde ich ja wirklich witzig, ne. Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist jetzt etwas über einen Monat in Kraft.
Ja
Ähm ich glaube äh es waren als erstes war es natürlich Bayern, die sagten, jo, alles klar, zack, die Daten kriegt jetzt der äh Verfassungsschutz,
der oder der Verfassungsschutz kriegt jetzt Zugriff auf diese Daten. Jetzt hatte ja der ähm.
Der Mars,
schon schon explizit ausgeschlossen, ne? Hat er gesagt, dass Verfassungsschutzamt ist in dem Gesetz nicht vorgesehen, für einen Zugriff nach den Regeln, die wir in diesem Gesetz vorschlagen werden. Das ist sehr witzig. Also nach den also
erkennt man auch schon wieder so, dass äh überspezifische äh dass er sagt so, nicht nach den Regeln, die wir hier vorschlagen, ist es erstmal nicht vorgesehen, aber,
quasi auf dem Fuße folgt, sofort die Ausweitung,
erst in Bayern über ein Landesgesetz und jetzt sofort als ähm als Position der CDU und dann offenbar sogar noch ähm.
Also zumindest in einem sehr nahen also es geht ja dann so, sie bezieht sich wieder auf äh Terror ähm.
Aber ohne richterlichen Beschluss, ne.
Aber es ist irgendwie drei Sätze hinter äh Asylberechtigte und Geflüchtete, ne? Also so, dass es,
im direkten äh in die in direkten Zusammenhang. Und natürlich ein Satz danach.
Logbuch Netzpolitik hatte das ja äh schon mehrfach angekündigt. Wir haben's auch auf dem CCC Jahresrückblick nochmal gesagt. Das war,
Das wussten wir, ähm dass halt im Quartal eins äh zweitausendsechzehn die Forderungen nach neuen Staatstrojanern kommt. Es heißt jetzt also hier,
in Form der Quellen-TKÜ und in Form der Onlinedurchsuchung, die sich ja ähm unterscheiden in ihrer,
in ihrer rechtlichen Grundlage die Quellen-TKÜ ist eine Maßnahme, die quasi unter den Abhörmaßnahmen läuft und äh wo man quasi sagt, okay, wenn wir von einem Richter die Befugnis
erteilt bekommen, ein Telefon abzuhören. Dann wollen wir das, sehen wir im Prinzip gleichbedeutend damit die Befugnis, einen,
Trojaner auf dem Computer des äh oder auf den Rechengeräten des der Zielperson zu installieren, der es uns ermöglicht,
verschlüsselt Kommunikation abzugreifen. Also wenn die Person verschlüsselte E-Mail schreibt, dann wollen wir die an der Quelle abgreifen,
wenn die Person verschlüsselte Kurznachrichten schreibt oder verschlüsselte Telefonate führt,
dann wollen wir die an der Quelle ähm aufzeichnen. Und das war ja schon, also das war das, was sie.
Grob irgendwie versucht haben gedacht haben zu dürfen und was dann mit dem Bayern Trojaner und den äh Verhandlungen vom Bundesverfassungsgericht dann eben auch untersagt wurde, weil es eben
äh technisch kaum denkbar ist, ein derartiges ähm System,
funktional zu bauen, dass es den Ansprüchen, den rechtlichen Ansprüchen genügt und dann noch dazu die Onlinedurchsuchung, die ja noch quasi viel schlimmer ist, wo sie nämlich sagen, naja, wenn wir,
Jemanden ins Haus dürfen und den und die Wohnung durchsuchen dürfen und den
Computer mitnehmen und den forensisch untersuchen dürfen, dann können wir doch bitteschön auch quasi ohne Wissen des Opfers einen trojanen äh der Zielperson, sorry. Ähm,
altes äh Hacker, alte Hacker, Dichotomie, ähm Angreifer und Opfer. Äh ohne Wissen des ähm,
der Zielperson einen Trojaner auf dem Computer installieren und uns dort umschauen. Also quasi eine Hausdurchsuchung in deiner Abwesenheit. Ähm.
Bei der man dann sehr praktisch auch einfach was liegen lassen kann.
Genau, bei der du dann eben, also das ist ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ich kenne tatsächlich habe ich jetzt diese ganzen Regelungen zur Hausdurchsuchung ähm nicht genau parat. Ich weiß, ich können die eine Hausdurchsuchung machen.
In Abwesenheit.
In Abwesenheit. Da brauchen sie wahrscheinlich irgendwie einen rechtfertigenden Notstand oder so.
Ja, das geht wahrscheinlich über so Gefahr im Verzug Geschichten, äh aber in der Regel eine normale Hausdurchsuchung ist so
mit dem richterlichen Beschluss und dann kann die Person in der Regel auf dem Papier auf jeden Fall sagen stopp, äh ich möchte mal noch ein Zeugen oder einen Anwalt oder so haben und dann müssen die auch noch warten. Äh ist wird oft gebrochen äh.
Gebrochen. Ich meine, du gehst einmal aus dem Flur raus, dann sagen sie, ja, der wollte irgendwas verstecken und dann knüppeln sie dich nieder und ähm ja, also äh.
Aber in der Regel ist sieht es natürlich das schon vor, dass da den Zeugen da hast, damit eben gesichert ist. Was passiert da, was machen die da? Und
schieben die, die nichts unter, ne? Das ist ja die Idee dahinter, ich kann das beobachten und die lassen jetzt nicht oh, wo ist denn auf einmal hier, da haben wir aber ein halbes Kilo Gras gefunden bei ihnen.
Aber okay, also es läuft irgendwie anders, aber wir sind hier bei der Onlinedurchsuchung,
Online-Besuchung zur Vorbeugung von terroristischen Aktivitäten. Also wir kriegen Ausweitung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Verfassungsschutz, ja, der Inlandsgeheimdienst kriegt Zugriff auf die auf die Vorratsdaten.
Dazu muss man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen, ne, also Vorratsdaten eigentlich,
auch wieder richterlicher Beschluss und dann kann ich darauf zugreifen. Wenn ich jetzt diese Daten einem Geheimdienst gebe, der eben nicht rechenschaftspflichtig ist oder ein sehr unausreichendem Maße äh,
dann guckt der sich halt einfach an, was das für Leute sind. Und ich kriege dann halt die, das neue super, wenn ich da über Monate äh mir die Daten anschauen kann. Äh das ist eine,
eine noch krassere Aufweichung äh,
das Rechtsstaat und der Möglichkeit, also das ist echt äh also das ist Totalüberwachung, man also man kann man finde fast keine Superlative mehr, ne? Also Forestantenspeicherung schon so schlimm ist.
Also stellen wir uns mal vor, stellen wir uns mal vor, was das bedeuten würde bei der, also die gleiche Gesetzgebung, bei dieser ähm Landesverratsgeschichte, ne?
Da hättest du halt quasi, da hätte der Verfassungsschutz schon,
Zugriff auf die kompletten Vorratsdaten der Netzpolitik Orkredaktion grundsätzlich gehabt.
Das ist schon echt amtlich, ne? Also das ist schon echt hart.
Ein bisschen genauer auseinanderklappen, Büchern, was jetzt hier schon ähm,
konkrete Gesetzesinitiativen sind, die schon auf dem Weg sind und wo wir jetzt nur über äh Vorschläge von Gruppen und Politikern reden, weil da komme ich gerade so ein bisschen aus der Spur und ich denke
das wäre nicht ganz unwichtig, dass wir auseinanderzuhalten.
Ja, also die.
Schutzparagraph hundertzwölf ist auf dem Weg als Bundesratsinitiative, ne, von Hessen. Ähm Schleierfahndung,
Ist CDU will er es haben. Ich weiß nicht, wie die SPD positioniert sich daher auch als Sicherheitspartei. Weiß nicht ganz genau, wie da der Stand ist. Ähm Asylgesetzgebung
ist beschlossene Sache, ne? Das hat äh ist schon aufm Weg mit dem schneller Ausweisen,
Ähm und sonst sind das ja glaube ich alles äh Forderungen, ne.
Genau, also.
Nichts, was wir nicht auch schon immer mal wieder gehört haben, nur dass es gerade so ein bisschen den Eindruck macht, dass einfach die Gesamtmenge äh in der Lage ist, das mal wieder sehr viel näher der Realisierung zu bringen, als das bisher der Fall war.
Also mir ein und dass das hier gerade eine Partei macht, die durchaus signifikante äh Vertreter in der,
Vertreter im Bundestag hat und in der in der Regel machen kann, was sie möchte, ne? Müsste jetzt nochmal mit dem, mit der SPD darüber quatschen.
Nichts Neues, dass die CDU in dieser Situation ist.
Ja ja, aber das, also ne, ist jetzt nicht, es ist nicht irgendjemand, der da was fordert, ne, das sind in der Regel die, die es auch machen, ja, also die die CDU droht nicht nur, die beißt auch, ne?
Und dann hast du da die Verfasstheit der SPD mit Gabriel, der halt durchaus sich als äh Partei der Mitte, Partei der Sicherheit präsentieren will und da der CDU das nicht überlassen äh will Sicherheit äh zu machen.
Sagen wir es mal andersrum, der so ein bisschen den Eindruck macht, als hätte er immer Angst, abgehängt zu werden, wenn er für die eigentlichen Werte seiner Partei äh einstehen würde, die irgendwo mal aufgeschrieben wurden.
Es ist nicht und dann hast du eh so eine Grundstimmung, bei der nach diesem Köln-Ding, die wie gefährlich ist, mit so einem aufm rechten Rand,
letzte AfD Bundestagsumfrage zwölf Prozent, da ist halt da sind die auch unter Druck, dass die CSU unter Druck nach rechts und geht da voll mit. Und da hast du so also, das ist mir gerade eine politische Gesamtlage, die nicht, nicht, nicht förderlich ist für
Bürgerrechte. Also.
Das ist eigentlich die immer wiederkehrende Diskussion,
Wie geht man einfach in krassen Situationen, wo man irgendwie äh in Medienattacke ist und wo es so gefühlte äh Stimmungsumschwünge äh gibt mit Radikalisierung? Wie geht man damit um? Ja, hält man, hält man
quasi seine seine Position, die man so in normalen Zeiten
aufrecht äh gehalten hat, äh auch weiter durch. Ja, oder hat man einfach Schiss, dass wenn man jetzt nicht,
irgendwie zumindest den Trend gefühlt nachgibt bis hin zu auch in in in größeren Teilen nachgibt, äh verliert man dann irgendwas. Wobei äh,
Da kann ich jetzt auch nicht zu klug daherreden, aber das ist ja so eine immer wiederkehrende äh Debatte, dass ich eigentlich,
Zumindest in vielen Beispielen auch immer wieder zeigt, in dem Moment, wo man halt,
dieser gefühlten Minderheit, dieser lauten Minderheit nachgibt, dass man damit ihre Themen überhaupt auch erst adelt. So.
Aber da da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich also ich glaube, dass,
gab's irgendwer so Politbarometer-Umfrage, härtere Gesetze und da sagen halt irgendwie siebzig Prozent der Deutschen jo. Was auch immer das heißt, Hertha Resätze eben nicht
das ist halt die Gefahr an diesem ganzen,
an diesem ganzen Thema Sicherheit ist, dass Politik halt sehr schnell handlungsfähigkeit beweisen kann und das immer weiter treibt und da kann ich was tun und da haben wir jetzt das verschärft und dann haben wir das nochmal und nochmal und das ist so ein Mechanismus, der äh uns äh zunehmend halt in eine unfreie Gesellschaft.
Treibt. Ich beißt nicht, wie man den wie man den,
Kann, ne? Also wie kann ich da rein, indem ich das klar da lege, was es bedeutet und
ob ich da Evidenz basiert irgendwie, ihr müsst mal Beweise voll, also das ist sehr schwierig, weil ich sehe da diese Menschen aus dem die für eine freiheitliche äh
Grundrechte, orientierte Politik, das ist halt leider ist es sind, ist das die Minderheit? Ähm das ist nicht einfach.
Ja, du hast halt immer diese wie diese Debatten abgehen, also es ist halt eine eine ein Teufelskreis, ne? Klassischer Fall von Teufelskreis in anderen,
ähm in anderen Bereichen versucht man Teufelskreise zu erkennen und ihnen entgegen zu wirken, aber ähm,
Also ich meine, auch so so irrsinnige Sachen wie wir haben das Reisen in terroristischer Absicht unter Strafe gestellt. Also wie willst du denn,
Ich meine, da da musste dich ja auch immer fragen, wie willst du denn diesen Nachweis führen? Den kriegst du doch das Reisen in terroristische Absicht, ja?
So in Terrorist, dadurch, dass wir offenbar den Terrorakt oder die Vorbereitung des Terroraktes hier nicht ergreift, so, sondern das Reisen in terroristische Absicht, ja.
Gegen die ganzen Leute, die irgendwo zu ISIS gehen oder.
Ja, ja, ist ja, natürlich muss man so Extremisten kann nicht nur der Pass, sondern auch der Personalausweis entzogen werden, um sie an der Ausreise zu hindern, ja?
Das sind ja also man erkennt ja, man kann ja verstehen, dass da irgendwie sinnvolle ähm Absichten,
irgendwie hinterstehen? Du fragst dich nur,
Erstens, was sind das für komische Maßnahmen und wie möchtest du diesen Nachweis, diese Nachweise führen? Und das sind ja letztendlich dann irgendwelche Strangen,
Gesetze und strange Maßnahmen, die du da ergreifen kannst.
Für die du in der Regel den den den die Beweiskette einfach gar nicht
liefern kannst oder die Beweiskette jetzt immer weicher definiert wird, sodass sie sie dann irgendwann halt liefern kannst. Und dann geht's irgendwann hin, ist das ganze Ding zu komplex und dann wird das alles wieder nochmal ein bisschen vereinfacht und der Zugriff und so weiter. Und dann hast du irgendwann
halten letztendlichen Willkürstaat. Und da du,
bisher zumindest einfach wirklich eine unglaublich geringe Anzahl an Terroristen und Anschlägen Hass. Ähm ist dann halt die nächste,
Immer wieder der nächste logische Schritt, ne? Du bist hast halt irgendwie an einem Punkt in die Tiefe gebohrt und dann musst du halt von da aus wieder in die Breite gehen. Und so läuft dieser dieser Teufelskreis äh die gesamte Zeit ab.
Na, ich ich finde in diesem ganzen äh äh,
Prozess mit Gesetzesverschärfungen und jetzt wird mit der also da wird ja immer der Rechtsstaat bemüht, der Rechtsstaat will muss jetzt durchgreifen mit der ganzen Härte des Rechtsstaates und so und diese also was was sich anschaut, was jetzt gerade in Berlin passiert ist mit.
Man sich ja auch immer fragt, ist das sonst nicht so? Also es ist.
Aber ich glaube, ein Rechtsstaat zeichnet sich ja gerade dadurch aus, dass er weder emotional irgendwie noch das er durchgreift,
bedeutet nämlich, ich greife hier durch und woanders nicht. Und ein Rechtsstaat zeichnet sich ja als das Ideal.
Es vorbei so.
An was vorbei durchgreifen, also ein Rechtsstaat zeichnet sich ja aus, dass er dass er ähm dass er eben alle Situationen erstmal,
bewertet und nicht irgendwie Ausnahmen macht eigentlich, das ist ja Rechtsstaatlichkeit und deswegen fand ich interessant in allen Diskussionen sowohl zu Köln wie jetzt auch,
Straße, linkes Projekt in Berlin, die gerade mit fünfhundert Leuten durchsucht wurden. Da wird gesagt, ja, da wird der mit aller Härte des Rechtsstaates durchgegriffen,
also das passt nicht zu dem Begriff Rechtsstaat und das ist, muss man den Diskussionen müsst ihr alle mal beobachten wie der Rechtsstaatsbegriff da eigentlich äh komplett falsch äh genutzt wird. Ähm.
Ja vor allem in Anbetracht der, was weiß ich, wie viel äh brennenden Flüchtlingsheime und potenziellen Flüchtlingsheime im letzten Jahr frage ich mich halt,
da eigentlich nochmal mit der Härte des Richtstaats dann war, also wenn das nicht schon genug anders gewesen wäre.
Das ist tatsächlich die große Frage, wenn ich irgendwie pro Asyl hat, grade irgendwie veröffentlicht irgendwie, dass es irgendwie jeden
Tag in zweitausendfünfzehn hat eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft gebrannt, jeden,
dritten Tag irgendwie und es gab über neunhundert Straftaten gegen Flüchtlingsunterkünfte in in zweitausendfünfzehn, das ist irgendwie viermal mehr als zweitausendvierzehn.
Vor allem wie viele Leute sind denn da gefasst worden?
Gab irgendwie.
Vollverurteilung bislang. Irgendwie wenig Hausdurchsuchung und also da das ist das, das ist schon äh fraglich und klar, wenn man das jetzt gegen so ein Dings stellt,
Was gerade in Berlin passiert ist und gerade diskutiert wird mit diesem äh linken Hausprojekt äh wo auf einmal zwei SEK Hubschrauber hat irgendjemand hat wohl,
hat einen Kontaktbereichsbeamten in der Straße geschubst, sagt zumindest der Speti oder Bäcker,
das beobachtet die Polizei das als schwere Körperverletzung. Wie gesagt, der Bäcker das beobachtet hat, meinte so, ja, die haben den ein bisschen rumgeschubst. Okay, egal, macht man nicht. Äh gehen in dieses Haus rein und ohne Täter zu suchen.
Äh und ohne Durchsuchungsbeschluss äh,
fünfhundert Polizisten und zwei SEKs für sieben Stunden durchsuchen das ganze Haus und tragen am Ende irgendwie,
wie war das? Zehn, zehn, zehn Tonnen Briketts Kohlebriketts raus, ein Einkaufswagen mit mit mit Stein und irgendwie ein paar Gitter, was auch immer, diese Gitter sind,
äh und da wird ein Feuerlöscher, genau, ganz gefährlich auch, ne? Ähm äh interessant, wie wie,
äh wie da der Rechtsstaat durchgreift und könnte es auch als politische Polizei sehen. Die, die sich, die sich also eindeutige Meinungen hat äh und der Begriff Vergeltung steht auf einmal im Raum,
gesagt, auch von staatlicher Seite oder von Henkel.
Vergeltung.
Das ist Vergeltung,
also und das ist halt eine Kategorie, die kannst du in einem Rechtsstaat nicht machen, denn die Polizei muss wieder nach den Grundsätzen von Verhältnismäßig.
Demnächst dann auch mit Vergeltungswaffen oder was.
Naja, wenn's nach der Depool gehe, also der deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft, das ist so, die Rechte, die Beamtenbund, die haben ja dann einen acht Punkte Programm dazu gefordert und fordern den,
Elektroimpulsgeräte sollen gegen diese Täter eingesetzt werden, also Taser,
in Deutschland nicht erlaubt und der neue Täterdatei, eine neue Fachdienststelle und so weiter und da ist auch der endlich hat der Rechtsstaat angemessen reagiert. So wird diese Polizeieinsatz aus die Sicht äh,
Also Rechtsstaat ist da was man daraus macht äh nutzt jeder, klingt immer gut. Ähm.
Rechtsstaat ist der eigentlich so eine zivilisatorische Errungenschaft.
Meint, die unbeeinflussbarkeit, ne? Nicht Erdogan sagt, ja, Gericht jetzt, den mache ich hauen wir jetzt aufs Maul und dann werden die verurteilt, sondern,
die Politik mischt sich nicht ein, es es wird unabhängig von wer ist es, also äh er hat ein faire Verfahren garantiert und so weiter, ne. Ähm.
Eigene gute Sache, so ein Rechtsstaat.
War, es war nicht alles schlecht im Rechtsstaat.
Gut. So, voranschreiten.
So. Ich würde sagen, ja.
Ja, dann war mal wieder eine,
der tolle Geheimdienstuntersuchungsausschuss, der die Wahrheit ans Licht bringt und dabei sollte diesmal helfen, die ehemalige BND-Chef,
Ernst Urlaub, der war äh geladen, wurde auch befragt und hat auch ähm Aussagen getätigt.
Es war ganz interessant, also Urlaub war BND-Chef von zweitausendfünf bis zweitausendelf.
Und er hat da so einen, ja, also das war jetzt durchaus mal,
ganz interessant, was er da erzählt hat. Also auch wieder offen, offensichtlich, was also und offenbar,
Was der erzählt hat, aber äh wie das eben im Rechtsstaat so ist, du brauchst eben auch immer einen Zeugen, der's nochmal erzählt, bevor du äh für deine Vermutung ähm jemanden verurteilen kannst. Und,
Als Erstes macht er jetzt dem de Maizire Schwierigkeiten, de Maizire hatte ja im Juni gesagt,
dass er zu Einzelheiten nix wüsste, insbesondere zu der Operation Eikonal. Damit war er also mit Einzelheiten war er da nie befasst, ne? Der hat.
Kooperation zwischen BND und.
Genau, das Kabel, das äh Projekt äh Kabel abhören in Frankfurt. Ähm und,
Also, ne, aus mit mit ruhiger Hand und Weitsicht und Augenmaß alles gemacht und selbst die Entscheidung dieses Projekt zweitausendacht einzustellen
sei ihm nur mittelbar zur Kenntnis gegeben worden, ne? Also der hat halt quasi da das Kanzleramt gemacht und hat da wenig
hätte da jetzt wenig mit der Tagespolitik oder so zu tun, jetzt nur weil er im Kanzleramt saß, ne?
Wert sind und sonst beschlossen, wenn nicht die.
Ja genau, da sagt er, äh sagt dann der äh Urlaub,
Also er kann sich ja jetzt wirklich nicht vorstellen, dass der Geheimdienstbeauftragte Klaus-Dieter Fritsche, der zweitausendacht ähm,
Während Steinmeier,
Chef des Bundeskanzleramtes war, war also Claus-Dieter Fritsche sein Geheimdienstbeauftragter und sagt Urlaub, also das könnte er sich beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, dass bei einem,
Bei einer Entscheidung derartigen Ausmaßes und dieser Tragweite, dass der ähm Fritsche, dem Steinmeier jetzt nicht erzählt hat, dass äh dass sie aufgehört haben, große Datenmengen am frankfurter Netzknoten der deutschen Telekom abzugreifen.
Ähm zu der Kooperation mit der NSA. Grundsätzlich hat er gesagt, ähm es gab natürlich von der NSA fortwährende,
Begehrlichkeiten,
mehr Daten und mehr Anschlüsse und mehr zu bewachen, äh mehr zu überwachen. Wir kennen das Muster, äh ähnlich wie bei der äh CDU und bei allen anderen äh Regierungen und Geheimdiensten dieser Welt. Es man will natürlich mehr
und diese stetigen Begehrlichkeiten ähm,
seien eben auch ein generelles Thema immer gewesen im Kanzleramt. Das war im Prinzip das, womit der Geheimdienstkoordinator die ganze Zeit befasst war. Insofern sagt er also es hätte es für absolut unwahrscheinlich, dass der äh Fritsche da irgendwelches Wissen für sich behalten habe.
Ähm man könnte interpretieren, äh dass der Urlaub äh höhere Solidarität zu hat als zu de Maizire.
Auf die eine Seite damit de Maizire durchaus belastet und äh Fritsche eben entlastet.
Und man muss dazu vielleicht noch sagen, aus äh der Biografie von Urlaub, der war nicht nur BND-Chef, sondern war ja selber mal äh Geheimdienstkoordinator im Bundeskanzleramt, also der kennt die Vorgänge und Verhaltensweisen da drin, wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut.
Und jetzt muss ich kurz was sagen. Ich habe einen, ich habe, glaube ich, grade Steinmeier und de Maizire mehrmals verwechselt, in allem, was ich voran gesagt habe, war die Rede von de Maizire.
Denn der war zu dem Zeitpunkt Kanzler und Minister. So Steinmeier.
Außenminister.
Ist heute Außenminister und war auch mal Kanzleramtsminister.
Aber da er ja nicht in der CDU ist, weil natürlich zu Merkel Zeit nicht Kanzleramtsminister, wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere.
Er ist ja Bodo Hombach, äh neunundneunzig äh gefolgt und ich glaube, bei Merkel ist er dann Außenminister geworden gleich. Also von daher war er unter.
Neunzig Gerhard Schröder, oder? Zum Staatssekretär beauftragten für die Nachrichtendienste.
Neunundneunzig wurde er Chef des Bundeskanzleramts.
Genau und hörte dann auf.
Nach Hombach, genau. War davor aber Geheimdienstkoordinator im November, war ein halbes Jahr Geheimdienstkoordinator und dann Kanzleramtsminister.
Okay, also die ganze Zeit war die Rede von de Maiziere und dann jetzt komme ich nämlich zu Steinmeier ähm und da sagt der Urlaub,
der Steinmeier war zweitausenddrei inhaltlich unterrichtet
über den Freibrief, der der Telekom ausgestellt wurde, äh oder der der Telekom der für die Telekom verfasst wurde, in dem festgestellt wurde, dass Alconal rechtmäßig sei. Wir ähm erinnern uns, dass die Telekom ja
Schon gesagt hat
Äh Freunde, was ihr hier machen wollt und so, das kommt uns ein bisschen komisch vor. Ähm vielleicht geht ihr nochmal zu eurem Chef und lasst euch kurz
sagen, ob das auch klar geht, was ihr da vorhabt, ja?
Weil die Telekom eben wie so viele Menschen in diesem Lande eine etwas andere Interpretation der äh rechtlichen Gegebenheiten hatte als jetzt in dem Falle
Der BND selbst, der der durch diese Gesetze reguliert werden sollte. Und er hat, Urlaub hat also selbst mit Steinmeier über,
Diese Zuwächse in der Datengewinnung gesprochen.
Und er hat auch mit Steinmeier darüber gesprochen, wie die rechtlichen Bedenken der Telekom ausgeräumt werden sollten. Und,
Er war nämlich Urlaub. Jetzt ist es, jetzt wird dieses diese Sopranos Clusterfuck irgendwie komplett,
auch mal Geheimdienstbeauftragter im Kanzleramt,
Und er hat eben darüber, äh er war also, Urlaub war, unter Steinmeier, der Geheimdienstbeauftragte im Bundeskanzleramt und er hat diesen Brief unterzeichnet,
In dem gesagt wird Kanzleramt meldet, geht klar, hat darüber vorher und nachher mit,
Steinmeier gesprochen und Urlaub hat dann diesen Brief unterzeichnet und August Hanning gegeben, der damals BND Chef war. Urlaub wurde das ja erst dann nachher. Also ui ui ui ui ui.
War aber auch,
der war auch mal ein Geheimdienstkoordinator, oder?
War irgendeiner nicht.
Das ist erledigt, ne, das ist eine das gehört irgendwie dazu, wenn man da so geheime.
Machen die auch mal so alle fünf Jahre mal so eine Party, so die Party, der ehemaligen Geheimdienstkoordinatoren.
Also wenn man Geheimdienstkoordinator ist, dann wird man auch irgendwie Geheimdienstchef nicht auch.
Hanning war äh BND Chef. Genau. Zweitausend.
Hallo. Das wäre jetzt mal ein Auftrag und an unsere visualisierende Hörerschaft.
Da könnte man so ein so ein Time Machine artig so man scrollt so durch die Zeit und sieht dann, wie sich die Köpfe immer im Kreis beweg.
Ich hätte lieber was übersichtliches. Also nee, aber das fände ich mal ganz schön, so eine so eine visuelle Timelin,
wo man dieses wer war, was eigentlich mal
keine Ahnung, wie das aussieht, aber dass das so diese Zusammenhänge wäre äh überhaupt, welche Felder schon mal bekleidet hat und wie das alles zusammenhängt zeitlich äh mal visualisiert, weil sonst.
Ich glaube, es gibt eine tatsächliche Zusammenhang mit dem, also wenn du Geheimdienstkoordinator bist, dann wirst du danach Geheimdienstchef, weil Hannig war nämlich da auch mit am Start und wurde dann,
also du wirst erst gehst im Kanzleramt, was da Geheimniskoordinator und dann wirst du BND Chef.
So, aber dann geht's, ähm dann haben sie sich noch mit dem Herrn Urlaub über die Ausweitung des G zehn Gesetzes auf Paket vermittelte Überwachung,
Und äh quasi dieses G zehn Gesetz war ja im Prinzip stammt aus einer Zeit, als es nur äh ähm was ist denn der deutsche Begriff für Circuit switcht? Ähm wie nennt man das.
Leitungsvermittl.
Leitungs vermittelt, okay. Also ja klar, leider.
Also es gab Leitungsvermittelte Verkehre vorher, ne, Telefon irgendwie, Frau sitzt äh zu Hause, ruft ihren Mann an und in der Vermittlungszentrale werden dann diese Kopfhörerstecker
umgesteckt, dann wird das irgendwann automatisiert und aber da gab es quasi ja immer eine tatsächliche.
Am Ende eine Leitung T.
Aus verschiedenen Segmenten zusammengesetzt war, aber.
Zusammengesetzt war, ob es,
Es gab quasi ein exklusives Signal, eine exklusive Tempo hergestellte Verbindung äh zwischen den beiden Gesprächsteilnehmern. Und die große Revolution der Telekommunikation und der Datenfernübertragung war dann das Paket vermittelte äh Übertragen von Informationen, wo also
digitale Geräte sich gegenseitig Signale zusenden, in denen quasi schon eine Routinginformation drinsteckt und es quasi keine,
exklusive Verbindung zwischen zwei Punkten mehr gibt, sondern viele, viele Switches, die ähm anhand großer Routintabellen dafür sorgen, wie einzelne Datenpakete am Ende zu ihrem Ziel gelangen. Was sehr viel komplexere
und sehr viel schnellere Netze ermöglicht hat.
Sogenannten virtuellen Verbindungen. X wird Größen X fünfundzwanzig.
Grüßen all das und wir grüßen wir begrüßen ausdrücklich nicht die Konsequenzen, äh die das für das G zehn Gesetz hatte. Denn jetzt musste man sich überlegen, ja, jetzt gibt's irgendwie, jetzt haben jetzt haben die da so eine neue Technik und so und jetzt müssen wir uns überlegen, wie,
wie weiten wir dieses G zehn aus auf diese neue Paket vermittelte Datenübertragung, die wir jetzt auch überwachen wollen.
Und da war dann die Leitfrage, haben denn vielleicht Kanzleramt und BND die G zehn Kommission und damit den Bundestag getäuscht?
Ähm denn.
Irgendwie haben die ja auf einmal äh Dinge überwacht in diesem Paket vermittelten Bereichen. Und wie gesagt, in dem Paket vermitteln ist dann auch irgendwie In- und Ausland nicht mehr so einfach, klar. Und er sagt, nee, nee, also das wäre ähm.
Ja, normal und klar, dass es bei den an die NSA weitergeleiteten Routineverkehren vornehmlich ähm um Auslandsbezug geht und so und ähm es wäre jetzt halt notwendig, das zu machen und den,
Parlamentskontrolleuren werde generell nicht mitgeteilt, welche ausländischen Dienste an einem Projekt beteiligt seien. Also es wäre quasi generelle Praxis,
dem der G zehn Kommission und den Parlamentskontrolleuren nicht zu sagen.
Wer da überhaupt mit.
Dass man damit mit ausländischen Geheimdiensten zusammenarbeitet. Ähm.
Weil es ja geheim.
Und deshalb hätte man dann eben die Millionen eingespeisten NSA-Selektoren, die vielfach rechtswidrig seien, äh rechtswidrig waren, äh der Kommission ebenfalls nicht vorgelegt. Muss man halt nicht.
Das verwirrt die auch nur.
Denn sowohl bei als auch bei der Satellitenerfassung in Bad Aibling sei man ja davon ausgegangen, dass der US-Partner wie ja zugesichert die deutschen gesetzlichen Bestimmungen einhalten werde,
sagte Urlaub. Und dann eben,
kommt dann so abschließend, ne, jetzt muss er, jetzt hat er ja eine Menge Leute in die in die Tinte geschubst und dann muss er natürlich so schließen mit, also während seiner Zeit, sei in ihm da keinerlei Probleme bewusst gewesen und er habe ja im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium regelmäßig
Über die gemeinsamen Projekte und deren Erfolge berichtet.
Mit halt dem einen Ausschluss.
Mitteilt dem einen Ausschluss, da sah halt dann eben nicht erwähnt hat, dass das mit der mit der NSA gemeinsam geschieht und das eben er nicht dahin geschaut hat, was die NSA da überhaupt einspeist.
Super gelaufen, war voller Erfolg.
Sonst alles super, ja? Sonst alles spitze.
Hm, geil.
Na, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, äh.
Sie ist sehr Steinmeier noch irgendwie auf der Liste. Kommt ihr nochmal? Ist der Miser nochmal geladen? Ich weiß es nicht.
Weiß ich leider auch nicht genau. Ich verfolge das dann.
Auf jeden Fall noch eine Menge zu holen.
Aber na ja, ich, also zentral war doch bei der Urlauaussage, dass sie es doch nicht erinnern konnte. Also ich finde das nicht so, also ich meine, äh geklärt werden konnten nicht, ob Steinmeier dieses genehmigt hat,
und und das da konnte er sich nicht erinnern, obwohl Urlaub das Teil unterschrieben hat. Er hat diesen Brief unterschrieben, das iconal, aber ob der Steinmeier,
Das kann ich nicht sagen, ne, aber ist halt auch schon.
Also er sagt ja schon, er habe mit dem darüber gesprochen, aber gibt's halt keine.
Nee, nee, aber er sagt nicht, dass er mit ihm unterschrieben und also das ist eher so, das nimmt den Steinmeier auch wieder ein bisschen hat er in Zusammenarbeit irgendwie das gemacht, ne. Das ist so die Aussage. Ich finde das das sieht das schon ganz.
Also da wir ja gerade so viel über den Rechtsstaat philosophiert haben, kann man hier halt eben auch sehen, ähm um da mal
Also wie aus, sage ich mal, der Perspektive einer
Strafverfolgung in dieser Rechtsstaat dann teilweise auch ärgerlich ist, ne? Weil eigentlich möchte man sich die Knaben ja einfach nur greifen, schütteln, denen eine Ohrfeige geben und sie bestrafen für das, was offensichtlich
hier geschehen ist, aber wir haben eben die
den Rechtsstaat, der uns da jetzt daran hindert, hier mit mit aller Härte vorzugehen und,
Vergeltung zu üben für diesen Angriff auf unsere Grundrechte.
Ein Thema äh von dem ich,
Ich dachte, dass es jetzt wirklich längst äh bei den Akten läge, hat nochmal den Bundesgerichtshof ähm beschäftigt,
Und zwar der der Freundefinder von Facebook. Ja, also ich ich hatte den in meinem,
meiner Wahrnehmung schon längst irgendwie unter abgehakt und tausendmal als rechtswidrig äh abgeurteilt,
Freundefinder geht so, du meldest dich bei Facebook an
Und ähm das Erste, was Facebook sagt, ist, ey, finde deine Freunde hier bei Facebook. Ähm gib doch mal kurz irgendwie dein komplettes Adressbuch und dann äh sorgen wir dafür, dass deine Freunde, die schon bei Facebook sind,
Dann auch hier jetzt dann deine Freunde sind. So und wenn Facebook jetzt das gesamte Adressbuch,
Wenn du dann Facebook dein gesamtes Adressbuch gegeben hast, waren da natürlich auch Menschen drin, die nicht bei Facebook waren. Vielleicht soll ja soll es ja.
Geben, soll's geben.
Es soll's geben.
Hört immer wieder davon, also.
Hier sitzen zwei.
Drei? Nee, ach so, äh, äh, ach so, zwei. Okay.
Na du hast mehr Seiten da angelegt als ich.
Eine? Ich ja, aber ja nicht als ich.
Ich bin bei Facebook, aber nur Undercover.
Ich bin da ähm im Geheim-Acco.
Aber mit der normalen Adresse, mit der normalen E-Mail Adresse.
Und äh genau, meldest du dich an, dann sagt Facebook, ey gib mal dein, gib doch mal dein komplettes Adressbuch, damit wir schon mal ein bisschen mehr über dich wissen und so.
Aber ich streite natürlich auch ab mit Facebook irgendwas äh sinnvolles zu tun und es ist mir auch generell einfach nicht erinnerlich, was ich damit schon getan habe.
Ich habe da so ein da kommen wir gleich nochmal kurz für, also.
Kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es da Kontakte gab zwischen Facebook und mir, über eine Webseite, aber über die genauen Details, das ist jetzt auch einfach zu lange her da. Habe ich keine genauen.
Also ich weiß auch, ich habe jetzt auch nicht mehr ich habe eigentlich, glaube ich, den Intendanten der Metaebene über das Erstellen der Logbuch Netzpolitik Facebookseite ähm informiert.
Ich habe das über die Medien erfahren.
Der Facebook-Untersuchungsausschuss,
So, also du gehst meldest dich da an, sagst hallo Facebook, ich will dir ich möchte mitmachen und so und dann sagt Facebook ja gib mal erstmal so als erstes als erstes Datenpfand äh kannst du uns ja mal dein komplettes Adressbuch hochladen und dann haben sie eben,
und die Leute, die da auf Facebook waren, haben sie dann automatisch äh zu deinen Freunden gemacht und die Leute, die nicht bei Facebook waren, haben sie gespamt. Ähm.
Pennen die Leute gesagt haben, willst du einladen, ne? Oder? War das nicht so ein Häkchen, aber weiß ich nicht. Ich bin ja nicht da.
Hm, daraus weiß ich noch nicht mal genau, also das geht aus der Kurzbegründung des Urteils nicht hervor.
Genau, dann bekam man diese Mails, wo schon irgendwie drei Freunde, die man kennt irgendwie, hey, die und die und die sind auch da, kommen doch auch.
Und das war eine Katastrophe und dann konntest du halt genau sehen, welche Arschgeigen.
Ihrer Dresdner.
Bei Facebook hochgeladen haben und dafür gesorgt haben, dass so und die der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband hat sich gegen diese Angelegenheit dann hier mit einer Klage zur Wehr gesetzt und es wurde abgeurteilt, dass das eben,
Den Tatbestand der ähm,
der der Massenwerbung oder der gezielten Massenwerbung ohne Einwilligung erfüllt. Ähm und Facebook hat dagegen argumentiert, ja, aber der Kunde lädt doch ein, der Kunde sagt doch, ich möchte diese Leute einladen.
Wir sind das doch gar nicht.
Facebook sagt genau, das sind wir ja gar nicht. Sind zwar.
Facebook sagt, dass sie das gar nicht tun, weil das ist ja nur der.
Steht er in AGB, dass dass du dann einlädst, ne, also man das ja, schön.
Und na ja, der BGH hat jetzt gesagt, also erstens habt ihr da die Empfänger belästigt und,
außerdem habt ihr den wussten die Leute die ihr Adressbuch bei euch hochladen nicht was sie da tun darüber habt ihr sie nicht ausreichend in Kenntnis gesetzt,
Und ihr habt also eure Kunden getäuscht, ihr habt äh da unlautere Werbung gemacht und so und auf der Seite war eben nicht erkennbar, dass auch nicht Mitglieder angeschrieben wurden.
Wisst ihr warum man nicht diese Mails nicht mehr bekommt? Das ist Thema ist ja durch, weil die Durchdringung von Facebook so hoch ist, dass es gar nicht mehr diese, willst du deine Freunde einladen? Beim Anfang gibt's halt nicht mehr.
Also ich glaube, es gab noch ähm,
Es gab noch einen anderen Grund. Es war eben diese diese Datenschutzgeschichte, ne, dass ähm da da gab's auch andere Verfahren irgendwie wie auf Basis des Datenschutzes, der ja hier erstmal in diesem Verfahren oder in diesem Urteil keine Rolle spielt,
und ähm im man liest in den Pressemitteilungen, dass der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband ähm,
die aktuelle Praxis von Facebook ähm gerade prüfen lässt
Also sie haben den Freundefinder in der Form nicht mehr. Der ist schon seit Jahren weg. Deswegen weiß ich, oh ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, es gab da mehrere
irgendwelche Datenschutzunabhängige Datenschützer, die die gemahnt haben und dann gab's wieder irgendein Verfahren, irgendein Verbot und hast du nicht gesehen, ich kenne den ich kenne das nicht mehr ganz genau, wenn man den Freundefinder auf Logbuch Netzpolitik
DE sucht, dann findet man da vielleicht nochmal was zu.
Ich habe mir da schon mal drüber geredet.
Ja, aber ganz am Anfang. Der war früher.
Verfahren. Es gibt nämlich andere Verfahren, da geht's darum, dass sie eben Daten von Leuten haben, die sich nie bei ihnen angemeldet haben, denn diese ganzen Freunde, Finderdaten, wenn ich davon genug habe, habe ich ja auch das soziale Netzwerk von jemand, der nicht dort ist. Und kann, habe da die Daten und,
dagegen gibt's auf jeden Fall Verfahren, dass du eben nicht betroffen bist von den Facebook äh wenn du nicht dich niemals so angemeldet hast.
Ich finde, LNP sechzehn äh.
Her, ne?
LNP sechzehn vom dreizehnten März zweitausendzwölf mit dem schönen Thema Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband gewinnt Klage gegen Facebook.
Mann.
Äh der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband gewann eine Klage gegen Facebook vor dem Landgericht Berlin. Das,
teilte die Kritik am Freundefinder und Teilen der Nutzungsbedingungen, die die kommerzielle Nutzung der Daten betreffen, Facebook kündigte umgehend an. Also für Nostalgica,
in der Facebook ähm Kritik äh kann man dann hier nochmal auf auf auf.
Wie merkst du dir das? Das wäre echt ein Rätsel irgendwie. Das ist jetzt schon fast vier Jahre, ja.
Du dieser dieser Freundefinder äh hat mich tatsächlich äh sehr geärgert. Also ich habe eigentlich ähm,
zu diesen Datenschutzthematiken wahrscheinlich mehr Zynismus als äh,
als ich vielleicht öffentlich bekanntgebe, aber dieser Freundefinder war einfach scheiße. Und ich habe dann auch Situationen gehabt, zu der Zeit habe ich ja noch ähm,
an Uni, an Universitäten, äh Seminare äh gemacht und dann habe ich auch teilweise äh kommen dann halt diese diese dämlichen Einladungen von,
von irgendwelchen Leuten, die dann, denen du dann, die dann da irgendwie ein Seminar sitzen und dann kannst du dir die direkt mal, ne,
Kannst du direkt mal einen roten roten Rand ans Referat machen? Nein, aber da da das da erinnere ich mich dran. Das war ein ein Ärgernis. Und weil du dann auch irgendwann festgestellt hast, in diesen Mails stand dann halt drin, so kennst du den, kennst du den, kennst du den? Und diese Mails wurden immer besser.
Ja, also wurde dann irgendwann so,
Kennst du deinen besten Freund und deine Exfreundin? Oder willst du mit der nichts mehr zu tun haben? So, das war dann irgendwie boah ärgerlich. Deswegen habe ich mir das äh gemerkt.
Vor allem wen man auch alles so in seinem Adressbuch hat, also allein die Annahme, dass man in seinem Adressbuch nur Freunde hat. Ganz mal davon abgesehen von diesem vollkommen verqueren Freundebegriff.
Ist doch Facebook egal. Hauptsache du, also wer dein.
Das ist denen egal, aber.
Freund ist, sehen sie doch äh daran, dass sie dem irgendwie fünfzig so komische Smiley-Nachrichten mit einem Selfie schickst. Äh da brauchen sie jetzt, da können sie ja ruhig erst mal alle deinen Freund nennen. Äh und wer dann wirklich Freund ist und äh erweiterter Bekannter, das sehen sie dann schon an den Mitarbeiterdaten.
Ach du meinst, die sind schon sozusagen über unser Verhältnis im Klaren, die ganzen sexing Aktionen da.
Kann schon sein. Also solange du darauf bestehst, hast du das weiterhin über WhatsApp machen.
Da. Uns ist nicht sicher.
Sicher. So sicher wie die Rente,
Cryptowals hast du hier nochmal als Thema äh ähm aufgenommen, Tim.
Das war der John.
Oh, John, ja dann erzähl doch mal was zu den Kryptowars.
Ja, da hat sich äh glaube ich gestern oder vorgestern die französische Ministerin für Digital Affairs wie das auf Französisch heißt, weiß ich nicht. Äh also die Internetministerin.
Affäre wahrscheinlich.
Ordinatös oder so was.
Der Oordinator ist hier der Rechner und ist digital.
Hat sich äh für Kryptographie ausgesprochen. Ähm und zwar wolle man nicht äh,
ja, weil das andere sei Verletzlichkeit. Ja, also auf jeden Fall hat sie sich, hat sich die französische Regierung für Kryptographie ausgesprochen und das hat von, äh, vor zwei Wochen auch oder vor zehn Tagen auch die äh niederländische Region getan. Ähm, es gibt also in diesem auch durchaus mal Sachen,
wo sich Bekenntnisse für äh für Kryptographie äh in Regierungen sind, die wobei.
Hast du jetzt hier noch ein ein den besten äh außen vorgelassen, denn der Michael Hayden,
der ehemalige NSA-Chef hat ja auch gesagt, Krypto-Finder gut, weil die Metadaten reichen ihnen ja.
Ja, also äh Michael Hayden hat auch vor vor wenigen Tagen dann äh das Bekenntnis zur zur ähm Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung geleistet und äh das sollte einen, das sollte einem Sorgen machen.
Also das muss man tatsächlich äh das sollte einem echt Sorgen machen, weil,
Ich meine, wir haben ja schon oft darüber gesprochen, dass eben die die Auswertung von Inhalten ähm,
sehr viel schwieriger, maschinell geschehen kann, als sie massenhafte Auswertungen von Metadaten Kommunikationsnetzen und so weiter,
aber, dass die diese Auswertung so gut ist, dass sie jetzt offenbar sogar öffentlich.
Dafür quasi sich dafür aussprechen, dass die Inhalte so vor ihren Augen verschlossen werden können, dass sie sie auch
Im Notfall und haste nicht gesehen und der Zug fährt
auf die Oma zu und wir müssen die vier Kinder retten, drehen wir die Weiche, also irgendwelche moralischen Dilemmatat, die da immer bemüht werden. Selbst in dem Fall nicht darauf zugreifen können. Das ist, äh, denke ich schon, nochmal ein Ausmaß, mit dem ich nicht gerechnet habe.
Was hat der Hayden gesagt?
Aber das auch Ehemalige, ne? Also wenn du da im Amt bist, willst du schon mehr.
Ist das so? Ich ähm hatte nicht Obama.
Also da gibt's auch eine andere Diskussion. Also äh es ist ja auch vor allem grad in den USA so ein bisschen der Krieg zwischen den äh Firmen des Silicon Valley,
voran äh äh Apple, also grad der Tim Cook, der Chef von Apple spricht sich ja extrem für äh Verschlüsselung aus und und und warnt alle äh davor ähm im Waldhaus, also ja
sollten da nicht Wischi waschi sein, sondern alles andere als No Backdoors wäre äh nicht akzeptabel,
schwer einzuschätzen, ähm welchen Status diese äh äh Debatte hat in dem Moment, wo so eine Unterstützung kommt, aber ich glaube, so ganz unwichtig äh ist das jetzt für die USA nicht,
Gibt's auch durchaus natürlich noch Leute, die das anders sehen.
Okay, dann verweisen wir hier nochmal auf den Vortrag Cryptowals beim zweiunddreißig C3, der auf meiner Liste der äh muss sie noch angucken,
ist, denn da wurde zumindest die Situation in den,
in den USA nochmal ausführlich zusammengefasst von einem Vertreter der IFF.
Und den Artikel auf die Intercept, der sich mit dieser Debatte mit dem,
ne.
Aber da, also, warum wir das Thema vielleicht so ein bisschen nebenbei behandeln, ist also.
Diese Zahnpasta kriegen sie eh nicht zurück in die Tube, zumindest nicht für die für diejenigen, die wertauf ernst zu nehmende Verschlüsselung legen. Ich halte nach wie vor es für eine realistische,
Ein realistisches Szenario, dass sie,
Massensysteme irgendwie infiltrieren wollen, also irgendwie so WhatsApp, Message und so weiter. Da haben wir aber, wie du ja grade schon anmerktest, dann ähm,
Die Silicon Valley-Vertreter, die da sehr äh strenge, sehr strengen Gegenwind leisten. Nicht zuletzt Tim Cook. Den Artikel hattest du, glaube ich, auch rausgesucht, Tim, ne?
Schon eine Liste.
Mein, das ist natürlich auch äh wird lustig, äh werden da mit Cameron in UK, der ja immer noch da äh der Meinung ist, er müsste alles verschärfen, aber Tim Cook hat halt einfach den längeren Hebel, ne,
nehmen wir euch äh nehmen wir euch unsere iPhones äh eure iPhones weg. Ja.
Man muss mal sehen, wie das, wenn.
Wasser mit dem Sozialstaatus.
Es wäre auf jeden Fall interessant, wenn dieses iPhone nicht mehr in UK verkauft werden darf, aber werde europäischen Binnenmarkt, dann kauft man halt in Holland oder sonstwo. Also äh.
Ja und dann bist du aber ruck zuck dran, wegen Einfuhr äh militärischer äh.
Viel Spaß.
Ja, ich meine, dann fallen Verschlüsselungstechniken wieder unter so einer äh Einfuhrkontrolle und dann haben wir echt mal einen Job, ey.
Wird dem Cameron so aufs Schwein gehen irgendwie, wenn die da in ihrem Bankenviertel nicht mehr mit ihren iPhones rumdadeln dürfen? Das kriegen die nie durch.
Kann man das so wenig vorstellen. Die die Schnappatmung, die da äh vorher steht, kann ich lange anhalten.
Und das ist halt also ich meine,
dass in das Ding ist, sie werden also sie werden wirksame Verschlüsselung nicht von diesem Planeten getilgt bekommen. Und äh die hohe Kunst der äh Steganographie,
ähm ist auch seit langem da und wird äh genutzt werden.
Also der verborgenen.
Man man versteckt quasi.
Dateien irgendwo, ne? Oder im Bild.
In Bildern oder in Audio, in was auch immer.
Du nimmst irgendein du nimmst ein Format, wo wo einfach sage ich mal das einzelne Bit jetzt nicht mehr so einen entscheidenden Einfluss hat
und ähm versteckst quasi in dem Rauschen, in der Introphie dieser Datei den verschlüsselten Teil deine deine verschlüsselte Nachricht.
Also wenn ihr zum Beispiel diesen Podcast dann auch rückwärts abspielt, dann.
Gibt's die wirklichsten Geheimbotschaften, die rechtsstaatlich.
Deswegen muss man das immer zweimal hören.
Ob acht, ob acht, äh das funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn du wenn du eine Datei nimmst, die die in ihrem Original äh der Angreifer nicht hat,
Also du könntest bitte keine Steganografie mit mit Originalepisoden von Logbuch Netzpolitik machen, weil da kannst du dann äh,
dann erkennen, dass meine Stimme auf einmal ganz anders klingt.
Klar, weil ich's dann vergleichen kann und sehe, die ist anders.
Genau, das heißt also, was auch, wenn sie da tatsächlich etwas machen, dann wird das immer die die Masse der Person ähm betreffen, die der Massenüberwachung dienlich sein und ähm ja.
Aber das hat er, das hat er auch wie heißt der, Mensch, der der FBI Chef ja auch eindeutig gesagt. Es geht darum, dass nicht alle das machen können. Es geht, dabei geht's gar nicht um die hoch organisierten,
die Terroristen, sonst wie, sondern man will nicht, dass Hinz und Kunz einfach sein Handy verschlüsselt, ne?
Wie heißt der Mann, FBI Chef, der die ganze Zeit ist ja gerade der Vorkämpfer in den.
War's, nee, ähm.
Mal gegründet.
Äh
Ist ein James. Von dem habe ich jetzt aber noch nicht.
Genau, Mister Comey. Das ist so der Hardliner in der ganzen Diskussion.
Mhm. Na super.
Ach ja. Schön, schönes Thema auch,
kommen wir kommen wir zum richtig schönen Thema.
Genau.
Video Streaming.
Netflix and Chill.
Genau, wenn ihr jetzt den Kongress irgendwie in den USA nachschauen wollt, dann müsst ihr unbedingt zu T-Mobile laufen
weil da kriegt ihr,
Alles jenseits eures Datenplans kriegt ihr einfach auf Video so in die Kehle gedrückt, bis ihr irgendwie nicht mehr papp sagen könnt,
aber leider irgendwie nicht in der gewohnten Qualität.
Nee, also es gibt da es es gibt da ein ein also ein eine Bilderbuchverletzung der Netzneutralität bei äh T-Mobile. Die haben wir also gesagt, ja.
Ich würde noch eins noch voranstellen. Äh also USA ist ja jetzt auch nur so
ja, aber auch nur so ein so ein also im Telekombereich äh auch nur so da äh hat man's halt mit zwei Platzhirschen zu tun, mit Horizon und AT und T. Und dann gibt's halt noch ähm,
Sprint und ähm Team Mobile ist so Platz vier, also so so der der Kleinste von diesen Anbietern. Bin jetzt gerade nicht ganz so sicher, ob nicht wieder irgendjemand irgendeinen gekauft hat in der letzten Zeit, aber Team ist
vertreten, aber halt ein verhältnismäßig kleiner Anbieter. Und hat sich in den letzten Jahren äh einen Ruf gemacht ähm.
Angebote zu machen, die so ein bisschen gegen den äh Strich gehen, wie das so normalerweise läuft, also sie haben viele Sachen auf einmal nicht mehr berechnet. Äh zum Beispiel kannst du so Sachen machen wie, das können sie hier übrigens auch mal einführen.
Dass wenn du jetzt deine Daten in einem Monat nicht verbraucht hast, dass du dir dann auch tatsächlich im nächsten Monat weiterführen kannst und sowas. Also, das ist also durchaus ein paar coole Sachen gekommen, sind auch die ersten, die jetzt angefangen haben, äh dieses
diesen dieses Ding mit äh du musst dann immer einen Dataplan äh immer ein ein ähm
mit dem Telefon sozusagen kommt auch immer der Plan, das ist ja in den USA nochmal viel verzahnter als das äh äh bei uns war. Also von TEM Mobile kam
immer wieder interessante Initiativen, weil sie da natürlich als Underdog auch in irgendeiner Form ein Angebot machen müssen, um sich irgendwie zu äh unterscheiden. Und besonders sichtbare,
Personen in dem ganzen Zusammenhang ist halt der Chef von äh Timo USA, dieser John äh leger. Das ist halt so ein Austeiler, so ein Freak, so ein äh Selbstdarsteller, der auch schon ein paar wirklich.
Grandiose Rahns abgelassen hat, weil er natürlich damit den äh großen Konkurrenten auch ein dankbares äh Ziel hat, ne. So haust du einfach mal auf alle drauf, da triffst du immer die Richtigen. Das ist schon so das Spiel, was er da
seit längerem Pferd und dafür ist er eben auch bekannt. Aber jetzt mit diesem neuen Binge-on, was sie dort,
eingeführt haben scheinen sie sich jetzt mal ein bisschen verhoben zu haben in der Außendarstellung.
Ja also was was ist Binge on? Binge und sagt erstmal grundsätzlich, wenn da ein Videostream kommt,
bringen wir den mit unserer probletären Technologie auf DVD-Qualität. Ähm.
Ne, weil die äh die Kernaussage ist vor allem erstmal du schaust Video. Es geht nicht von deinem Datenplan.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich würde genau, ich habe mir schon was dabei gedacht, andersrum.
Okay, dann mach mal.
Grundsätzlich jeder Videostream, wird auf DVD-Qualität runter manipuliert.
Damit werben sie aber nicht primär.
Kann ich das jetzt bitte mal kurz erklären?
Also grundsätzlich jeder Videostream wird äh wird auf DVD-Qualität runter gemacht. Das ähm spart dir ähm im Zweifelsfall ähm Volumen.
Datenvolumen, was du hast, ähnlich wie übrigens hier die äh bei Vodafone gab's das, glaube ich, auch und so, dass sie dir die Bilder kaputt gemacht haben, ne? Da sitzt ein Proxi zwischen und der der macht dir aus jedem
JPEG irgendwie so ein grobe ein grobes grobe zwei Pixel, die irgendwie in in Farbverlauf zwischen sich haben oder so, ne?
Das machen sie grundsätzlich erstmal bei allen Videos. Und zusätzlich gibt es dann Partner,
bei denen dir dann der Traffic auch nicht berechnet wird. Und da haben sie irgendwie sowas wie äh wie sechzehn oder annähernd ähm zwanzig äh Partner,
Streams aller Art, egal von wem, überträgt die Telekom eben höchstens mit anderthalb Mbit pro Sekunde, wenn du dieses Binge on ein anhast. Das heißt, ist, dass das gilt für alle,
Und,
auch die, die eben bei Binge nicht mitmachen, zum Beispiel bei YouTube, kann's also mit Binge on, gehst du auf YouTube, guckst ein HD Video, kommt und mach dir das weg und rechnet dir dadrunter, weil DVD-Qualität reicht ja für dein kleines Telefon.
Wie sind das eigentlich, wenn das überhaupt die PS kommt?
Ich gehe davon aus, dass sie oder ich würde erwarten, dass sie das sie dann da halten und fertig,
Ich meine, sie haben ja die, sie werden ja Zertifikate haben, die auf dem Telefon liegen. Ähm ist aber auch wieder eigentlich nur ein Nischenphänomen, weil du eben die meisten Videostreams kriegst du nicht über HTTPS.
Kriegst du halt einfach äh du hast ja genug mit deinen Streaming-Servern zu tun, äh wenn du jetzt irgendwie Netflix bist oder sowas. Ähm oder Net bei Netflix weiß ich's jetzt noch nicht mal so genau, aber die meisten kriegst du halt einfach mit irgendeinem,
DRM oder so
Du hast ja, du hast ja ohnehin häufig irgendwie so eine, wenn das jetzt so ein Bezahldienst ist, eh noch mal DRM drin. Deswegen kann's dir dann egal sein. Also wie es auch im Detail ist, ist mir jetzt spielt da jetzt gar nicht so eine Rolle
Sie gehen also hin und machen dir deine Videostreams äh Männer, die in ihrer Qualität und haben gleichzeitig,
Binge on Partner, äh bei denen dann der Traffic eben nicht berechnet wird. Und er sieht das,
ein großartiges, innovatives, tolles Geschenk an die Kunden.
Dass sie sagen, ey, Video war irgendwie euer Problem und äh erstens bei den, bei unserem Partnern
müsst ihr das geht das gar nicht mehr zu Lasten eures Volums und bei denen, die nicht unsere Partner sind, machen wir euch die Qualität so nieder. Äh dass das auch nicht mehr signifikant auf euer Volumen geht. Deswegen könnt ihr viel, viel mehr
ähm könnt ihr viel, viel mehr wünschen. Und dann gibt es also jetzt zwei Videos,
Ich glaube, das was du jetzt gerade da hast, ist das ältere,
Nee, das ist das, also er hat einen längeren Rand, wo er also diese Argumentation vorführt, wo er äh vorträgt, weil er sagt, hey, guck mal, was alles geiler ist und jetzt kommen hier irgendwelche Spacken und treten uns den Legoturm um und und heulen rum und behaupten, wir würden irgendwas, das stimmt ja gar nicht, die Videos sind ja genauso schnell, um
genauso lang wie vorher auch.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich.
Und dann stellt er sich, also eigentlich würde ich das erste Video auch mal in voller Länge wiedergeben. Das ist eine interessante.
Äh hast du denn da mal einen Link für mich, weil den hatten wir jetzt hier irgendwie nicht.
In dem in dem heiße Artikel eingebettet, der dort.
In dem heiser Artikel. Jetzt muss ich natürlich erstmal,
ähm gut, dass wir vorbereitet sind. Das ist doch, das ist doch schön.
Das ist einfach das obere der Videos, so.
Ah ja.
Critics und da muss man sich der Typ ist CEO dieses Unternehmens und das.
Aus wie Bayern München äh Arzt, Meier, Müller, Wohlfahrt, oder? Nee, okay, aber hier dieser Typ da.
Finde ich jetzt eine interessante Assoziation.
Der genießt es natürlich auch in diesem ganzen Telekom-Laden, der äh totale äh terriblitze sein und wenn die da Hauptversammlung haben, der da auftaucht, dann ist er wahrscheinlich der einzige ohne Schlips und so und äh liebt sich sozusagen auch in seiner ganzen Außenwirkung. Und das war
bisher auch recht unterhaltsam. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so ganz äh ununterhaltsam, aber
Na ja, ich glaube, der verrennt sich hier, dann spielen wir mal hier Video eins. Äh.
Ich unterbreche das mal, weil das ist jetzt wirklich nur bla bla. Äh und ja, das ist das, was er so als Records-Trade äh bezeichnet. Mögen jetzt noch ein paar interessante Aussagen äh danach kommen.
Jeden Fall hat er dafür natürlich ordentlich äh Flak bekommen.
Er kündigt am Ende dieses Videos eben an, dass er jetzt gleich äh irgendwie im weiteren Verlauf des Tages über Paris Scope äh dieses dieses Video Twitter ähm,
ein ein machen würde und da könnte man dann eben Fragen eintippen und er sitzt dann offenbar echt so an seinem Mobilgerät. Also es ist schon irgendwie so ich meine, man stelle sich vor, Tim Höttge ist
würde so auftreten.
Ja, dafür ist er übrigens auch bekannt, dass er solche Sachen macht. Also er hat äh extrem bei Timo extrem diese Nummer, die halt ja irgendwie komplett anders aufgestellt, also
äh der ist äh bekannt dafür, dass er sich immer wieder einmischt und auch selber da auftritt und so. Na ja, aber dann kam halt unter anderem äh eine Frage der IF, der Electronic Front Foundation. Äh na ja, wie nennt das so äh sei, äh ob denn Binge on
diesen Videostream äh auch ändert, so und ich.
Oder ob sie nur, also äh verändert bin schon das Video in irgendeiner Form oder limitiert bin nur die Band.
Also Obdachlosen ist oder ob der sozusagen richtig in den Videostream rein.
Frage ist deshalb so schön gemein, weil wenn sie sagen.
Egal was er antwortet. Genau.
Sie die Bandbreite begrenzen, ist es also ne und dann dann das wäre eine wäre wahrscheinlich die sinnvollste Technik, denn all diese Streaming Services,
eine,
sind adaptiv, insofern wäre das die eleganteste Lösung, das genauso zu tun da kommen wir auch zu dieser Frage, HTTPS, ne? Wenn sie da nämlich einfach Bandbreiten Limitierung machen, dann kann denen völlig egal sein, was in dem HTTPS drin ist
Wenn sie aber riesige Farmen irgendwo stehen haben, die den Videostream nochmal um äh äh umkurdieren,
Dann wäre das auf jeden Fall die teurere Lösung und wäre ein Eingreifen in den Content, was am Ende noch schlimmer ist.
Ja und beides verletzt im Prinzip ja auch die Netzneutralitätsregeln in den USA, muss man sagen.
Beides ist eine genau, insofern war die Frage sehr schön und wir hören seine Antwort.
Genau, obwohl er sich dann nochmal richtig verrennt.
Oh Mann, ey.
Warum manchmal so auch ganz gut beraten sind, wenn dazwischen nochmal so eine erfahrene Pressestelle die Aussagen filtert, weil ich glaube, die hätten ja dann schon nochmal irgendwie am Rockzipfel äh festgehalten. Also das wundert mich wundert mich auch ehrlich gesagt sehr,
Also ob das jetzt nur so gespielt war, ja? Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass dass er in seiner Rolle mit der IFF keinen Kontakt,
hatte. Also das nimm dem Diss irgendwie nicht ab. Das kann auch nur so ein Spruch gewesen.
IFF ist halt einfach mal ernstes Geschäft. Also die ist seit wie vielen Jahrzehnten aktiv? Seit neunzehnhundertneunzig. Seit neunzehnhundertneunzig.
Seit neunzehnhundertneunzig. Seit neunzehnhundertneunzig. Also fünfundzwanzig Jahre, sechsundzwanzig Jahre.
Genau, die hatten ja letztes Jahr, glaube ich, irgendwie auch groß gefeiert, ne? Da war irgendwie das Ding.
Ja, also die gibt's schon so richtig, richtig lange und vor allem gibt's die schon, bevor Internet überhaupt Xing war. Also, ne, also das das ist das ist wirklich bemerkenswert, wie früh die sich eigentlich aufgestellt haben. IFF ist eigentlich,
Also, was heißt eigentlich? An der Stelle ähnlich,
Visionär wie ist auch der Club von Anfang an war, wo halt einfach die ganzen Auswirkungen so früh gesehen wurden und auch schon die potenziellen Einschränkungen davon, so früh gesehen wurden, dass man sich da halt stark aufgestellt hat.
Barlo hat das gegründet und ja und dass er einfach nicht weiß, wer die IFS das kann ich mir irgendwie gar nicht vorstellen.
Die arbeiten mit so einem jährlichen Budget von paar Millionen Dollar.
Man weiß auch wer sie bezahlt.
Ja genau, nämlich die Leute, die da Geld hinspenden, damit so knirchen wie ihm, irgendwie ein Gegengewicht äh äh entgegengestellt wird, ja, also das ist wirklich,
das ist,
eine sehr schmale Planke, auf die er sich da begibt, weil im Zweifel die Leute, die die IFF bezahlen, sind diejenigen, die auch ihn bezahlen und wenn er äh sich da nicht verrennt, entscheiden sich die Leute vielleicht ähm einen von beiden kein Geld mehr zu geben,
Aber genau, da äh setzt er natürlich auch drauf. Und ich würde da jetzt man kann da natürlich als jemand als als Person, die die IFF äh äh kennen,
ähm so drüber lachen, dass er da eben so frech äh die IF herausfordert. Aber ähm,
Wenn man sich mal anschaut, was es so für Verschwörungstheorien in generell in der Gesellschaft gibt
Und grade so in diesem in diesem unter Bereich der Größeren Unternehmen ist es in der Tat so, dass gerade so diese Frage, wer bezahlt die,
Die beschäftigt diese Vorstände und höhere Management in der Tat, weil den,
Also wenn sie mit einem Gegner zu tun haben, ja? Wer bezahlt enormes?
Wer bezahlt die? Die haben doch ein finanzielles Interesse. Sowas macht doch keiner. Das ist doch hier eine PR-Stadt, das ist doch ein Angriff unserer Mitbewerber, ja. Also es sind ernsthafte.
Was er ja auch oft so ist, ja, diese ganzen Scheinorganisationen, diese ganzen Astro Turf äh Initiativen, das ist ja, das ist ja vollkommen normal in den USA.
EF ist halt klassisch Astrotörfler.
Klassisches, ja.
Das ist halt richtig Gras gut so, ne, aber es gibt halt auch genug äh Astrotörfe, sehr viel mehr Astro Turf als äh Gras-Ruth, so dass sie sich natürlich da auf halb acht Stellung sind, aber hier ist es halt einfach komplett unangemessen und vor allem, ich wundere mich so ein bisschen, nachdem
Beschlüssen, die ja jetzt gefällt worden sind und der generellen Ausrichtung der Netzneutralität in den USA, die ja,
So ist, wie wir uns das hier in Europa auch gerne äh gewünscht hätten weitgehend. Dass sie überhaupt noch mit so einem Dienst an den Start gehen können,
weil das wäre ja sogar hier noch schwer durchzufechten mit äh Spezialdienste und Hass nicht gesehen, weil
dass das einfach extrem äh eingreift, auch gegen die EU-Legislation jetzt äh verstoßen würde. Meiner Auffassung nach zumindest, probieren könnten sie es natürlich trotzdem erstmal und vielleicht kommen sie auch noch auf die Idee, ist ja immerhin die Telekom,
Sommer nicht vergessen. Ja und äh er musste sich auf jeden Fall äh entschuldigen oder saß ich dazu genötigt,
ähm ja, ja, das, das, das, das, da klar. Ich meine, der hat der hat da so äh der Schuss ging eher nach hinten los.
Ähm,
Warum das jetzt gerade geht, ist äh also die Geschichte der Netzwerk in den ähm in den USA ist natürlich auch eine lange,
Ähm und zwar gab es ja,
versuche der FCC, Netzneutralität zu erzwingen, zwischen zweitausendfünf und äh zweitausendzehn und dann gab es,
den äh den Google Horizon Deal, der da irgendwann mal kam, als als Lobby ähm,
Lobbyeinfluss auf diese Sache, dass man sagt, okay, lass uns Netzneutralität machen, aber bitte nicht da, wo Funk ist. Und dann erinnern wir uns ja, dass schließlich gegen die FCC ähm,
äh rechtlich vorgegangen ist und die die,
quasi der FCC die rechtliche Grundlage dafür abgesprochen hat, sich überhaupt im Bereich der äh der der Netzneutralität zu engagieren. Insofern ist die Netznetralität in den.
USA jetzt auch wieder in irgend so einer komischen Schwebe. Ja, es gab dann den den Internet Shutdown und da da gibt's also weiterhin ähm,
grade eine fast ähnliche Schwebe wie in in Deutschland. Und ich bin mir gar nicht mehr,
ganz sicher, was da jetzt überhaupt nachdem der der FCC da eben ihre Grundlage weggeklagt werden sollte. Im Moment äh der,
geltende Bereich ist, weil klar irgendwie Networks hatte die FCC nochmal im Februar zweitausendfünfzehn,
ähm veröffentlicht, aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, inwiefern da jetzt überhaupt die generelle äh,
Gültigkeiten äh noch in Frage steht oder nicht.
So oder so zeigt das Beispiel mal wieder sehr schön äh was ich die ganzen Telekom-Unternehmen, Mobilfunkunternehmen vor allem äh gerne noch einfallen lassen würden ähm oder was alles noch so in der Schublade liegt, wenn man denn nur dürfte, ja?
Das ist halt immer wieder das Ding, diese Wegelagerei und das das Schema verfestigt sich auch. Man nimmt halt Sachen
macht sie's Gas, also schafft entweder mangelnde Bandbreite oder greift eben hier sogar aktiv in in so eine Verschlechterung ein und danach verkauft man die die die Wiederherstellung des Normalzustands und und das ist eigentlich die das ganze absurde
was äh durch eine gesunde Netzneutralitätsregelung verhindert werden, äh soll und.
In Anbetracht korrekter Gesetzgebung dann auch äh verhindert werden würde. Und äh,
Diese ganze Argumentation mit Spezialdienste und wir müssen ja die,
sicherstellen, weil sonst wäre es ja nicht gut so, ja, also immer diese diese Illusion, dass dass das ganze Netz ja an sich kaum zu händeln wäre und unheimlich äh,
äh herrscht oder sagen wir einen Mangel herrscht, der aber eigentlich nur eine künstliche Verknappung ist. Äh,
greift halt alles nicht. Wenn wenn die Telekom der Meinung ist, die Daten kommen nicht schnell genug, dann sollen sie halt schnellere Leitungen bauen. So und wenn sie halt noch äh in Deutschland, ich will mich jetzt nicht zu sehr wiederholen, aber mich kriegt das auch auf, wenn wenn sie halt äh
nochmal ein Jahr und nochmal ein Jahr und nochmal ein Jahr, ihr äh scheiß Kupferkabel hier äh durchsetzen wollen, äh dann wird es halt auch nicht besser. Hätten wir einfach mal vor zehn Jahren angefangen, hier konsequent überall Glasfaser in den Boden reinzuschmeißen, dann wäre das Ding halt irgendwie jetzt auch überhaupt gar kein Ding mehr.
Mann, Mann, Mann, zehn Mega.
Ihr das schon mal gefordert?
Zehn Megabit. So, es regt mich wirklich auf.
Äh Ladies. Kürzlich war Klappe und nervt aber auf allen Ebenen. Also.
Deutschland ist irgendwie jetzt auf Platz siebenundzwanzig irgendwie so in Bandbreitenausbau angelangt so. Ja, ja, führende Industrienation mit geiler.
Aber in der Mainzer Erklärung der CDU wird es gefordert, der Ausbau der Infrastruktur. Echt? Ja, ja, also.
Ach echt? Du sollst dich fordern, du sollst machen. So, die nicht in der Regierung.
Oje. Ähm generell zu den Themen der Netzzentralität kann man natürlich jetzt auch nochmal
zwei zwei Talks von zweiunddreißig C drei empfehlen. Einmal
Ähm und dann natürlich von äh unser aller Thomas Lohlinger.
Mhm.
Aber schon geil, dass diese Debatte, also diese Debatte wurde nie rational geführt und ähm inzwischen wird sie halt mit mit Fuck und Jerk geführt, zumindest von diesem Vertreter hier. Das ist echt schön.
So, wollen wir unsere bereits ausgediente Sendung nochmal ein weiteres Thema verlängern?
Selbstverständlich, wo wir doch grade so schön von Videostreaming äh gesprochen haben, haben wir eine.
Nachricht vom CCC Frankfurt erhalten. Die haben wir ja sogar jetzt exklusiv schon äh in der Freakshow ähm verkündet und,
wo ich zu Gast war. Ja, genau, ich war zu Gast in der Freakshow. Hinten, das ist so ein, so ein Nischen-Podcast. Äh.
Wird auch schon deine dauerhafte Anwesenheit hier gefordert auf Twitter.
Ja, ich war ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass Dennis nicht da war. Ich wollte eigentlich mit Dennis Podcast, ich hatte mich so gefreut mit Dennis supporten, aber.
Auch gern gesehen.
Ja, mal schauen. Vielleicht habe ich ja irgendwann nochmal Gelegenheit, äh da äh nochmal eingeladen zu werden. Wenn Dennis auch da ist.
Könnte sich sicherlich ergeben.
Ja genau, also da haben wir, da haben wir auch schon drüber gesprochen, insofern können jetzt Skype drücken, wir sprachen den Lokbuch Netzpolitik über die,
CCC TV App die Mitglieder des CCC Frankfurt entwickelt haben und dort dann in den,
Review Prozess, dem dem Review-Prozess zugeführt haben, der einer Veröffentlichung im Apple, App Store vorangeht und da gab es dann acht Talks, die die der ähm,
dann da gesehen hat, wo er meinte, ey, der geht da gar nicht und äh da ging's halt um um Hacking, völlig überraschend und ähm das waren also teilweise echt irgendwie, ja,
Wohnen,
Apple nun wirklich, wenn überhaupt, dann sehr periphär äh tangiert wird. Ähm aber auch mal einen Talk über eine Einführung zu generellen Konzepten des JBRAX von Mobiltelefonen.
Und jetzt standen wir da ähm denn die es wurde quasi,
verwehrt diese App in den App Store aufzunehmen und es wurden dann
lange Gespräche geführt und es gab dann auch Berichterstattung natürlich Preise wo dann gesagt wird hier Apple zensiert den den CCC und dann gab es gleichzeitig das Vorgehen von,
Toto, der ja seit einigen Jahren immer die Congress-App macht und auch äh immer weiter entwickelt, ähm Toto äh,
hat dann quasi die die diese,
eigentlich ursprüngliches Geduld, wo man also während der Konferenz den Fahrplan sehen kann, erweitert, um um mehrere Features unter anderem, dass du jetzt eben mit dieser App dir die Aufzeichnung anschauen kannst von diesen Talks,
und diese App dann auch auf das Apple TV gebracht und äh Totus Vorgehensweise war einfach zu sagen, dass er,
Quasi dazwischen nochmal einen Server stehen hat, mit dem er kontrolliert, welche Inhalte diese App anzeigt und als dann der der Review-Prozess stattfand, hat er eben war eben dort nichts zu sehen, weil.
Eine Auswahl gab's.
Beispielvideo, irgendwas über also,
ich erinnere mich nicht mehr genau, was das war. Aber ähm ein Beispielvideo von von einer vorangegangenen Konferenz äh und wo dann also ein Bezug zu Apple nicht gegeben war, so hat er seine App durch den Appstore bekommen,
Und in dem Moment, wo sie freigeschaltet war, hat er eben auf seinem Server ähm weitere Inhalte anzeigen lassen, äh so eben dann auch die im Review-Prozess von der anderen App, die sie jetzt nur für das Apple TV war,
Und nur für die Wiedergabe von Inhalten von MediaCC. Dafür aber von allen, ja? Ähm,
der Beanstandung ausgesetzt waren. Also die eine App Congress ist also durch und diese App
äh CCC TV war also weiteren Diskussionen ausgesetzt, die wurden geführt, da wurde telefoniert, da wurde hin und her gemailt und so weiter. Und am Ende wurde eine Einigung herbeige
führt, die darin besteht, dass die acht bemängelten Talks ähm,
Quasi als zensiert in der App markiert werden und dort ein Link gezeigt wird, wie man sie eben im Browser anschauen.
Also der CCC ist eingeknickt.
Der die Entwickler dieser App aus dem CCC Frankfurt haben es vorgezogen, eine App in den Store zu bringen, statt,
keine App in den Store zu bringen und damit maximal darauf hinzuweisen, dass hier eine Zensur von Apple stattfindet.
Gleichzeitig gibt's aber natürlich auch die äh nun vertretene Interpretation, dass der CCC an dieser Stelle vor Apple eingeknickt ist und sich hat, zensieren lassen. Ich denke, beide
Für beide Interpretationen gibt es eine faktische Grundlage. Die App ist jetzt zensiert.
Aber es steht da halt auch drauf.
Aber es steht halt knall in knallrot da drauf und zukünftige ähm zukünftige Talks werden auch nicht mehr zensiert. Nun.
Halt, es gibt.
Ist, ich meine, ich kann mir das jetzt auch nicht anders vorstellen, als dass sie,
im Prinzip verstanden haben, dass sie sich da auf sehr dünnen Eis äh bewegen so und äh,
Würden sie jetzt ihre Argumentation folgen, müssten sie ja im Prinzip so ein Auge auf diese App haben und sich jedes Video anschauen, was halt genauso.
Eben nicht, ne.
Sinnlos ist, wie das bei YouTube auch zu machen und an der Stelle greift ja auch diese Argumentation, dass dass die App halt nicht der Inhalt ist so und äh diese Vermischung, das ist halt einfach das Verquere. Und äh es ist wirklich äh albern auf so vielen,
Ebenen und was er halt ausgehandelt wurde, ist halt ein Kompromiss. Und in gewisser Hinsicht finde ich sogar das Endergebnis noch lustiger jetzt
weil das sie da wirklich sitzt auf diesen blöden acht Videos, die eigentlich,
wahrscheinlich kaum jemand interessiert hätten, nennenswert, zumindest, ja, also es ist nicht der Grund, warum man sich irgendwie diese App zieht. Äh daran jetzt festbeißen, nur damit irgendein Mitarbeiter da äh sein Gesicht nicht verliert,
ja, darum geht's ja dann letzten Endes, ne? Sich dafür so 'ne, so 'ne,
hier Inhalt werden zensiert, App auf ihrer Plattform zu also ist das ist schon wieder ein Hack für sich.
Ja, also es ist halt ich meine, es ist für alle Beteiligten doof, ne. Es gab natürlich auch äh ähm Stimmen, die gesagt haben, lasst diese, lasst diese dämliche
ähm App halt raus, aber das ist natürlich auch irgendwie was, was,
Natürlich ärgerlich ist für die Entwickler. Und ich, wie gesagt, ich halte diese App für einen massiven Zugewinn für die Plattform und wir freuen uns natürlich auch über den
die späte Aufmerksamkeit, die den acht äh Talks aus den vergangenen Jahren da nochmal äh zuteil geworden ist.
Genau. Weil das ist ja im Prinzip die höchste Auszeichnung überhaupt.
Es ist aber natürlich ja genau, das ist eigentlich eine hohe Auszeichnung, aber ähm.
Könnte man nochmal so als so als so ein noch mit auf die Webseite mit draufnehmen, dass man danach aussuchen kann und so. Apple Sensor.
Apple Zensur.
Äh ja, sonst ähm.
Tag.
Vielleicht ist aber auch das letzte Wort in der Angelegenheit noch nicht gesprochen. Werden wir sehen.
Genau. Ohne große Fanfare diesmal haben wir noch einen kleinen Terminblock. Der besteht nämlich nur aus einem einzigen Termin, weil ihr ja entweder keine Veranstaltung macht oder uns nichts davon erzählt.
Das gibt Mails.
Ja, das war auch Sinn der Aussage.
Dann gib mal deine E-Mail-Adresse. LNP.
Ja, Dinos.
Meterebene Punkt ME ist, glaube ich, die unter der man uns erreichen kann.
Mhm. Genau.
Und zwar ähm richtet der Chaos-Treff Dortmund ein eine Veranstaltung aus, nämlich
einen Vortrag über Intel Exit des Penkollektivs ähm den Vortrag oder das Bankkollektiv war mit einem Vortrag über Intellexit auch auf den zweiunddreißig C3 vertreten. Ähm hier habt ihr jetzt die,
Gelegenheit, diesen Vortrag noch einmal live zu sehen und zwar am Montag, den fünfundzwanzigsten Januar, am
Im Seminarraum unterm Dach in der Braunschweiger Straße zweiundzwanzig in vier vier eins vier fünf Dortmund. Um einundzwanzig Uhr.
Ja, wer hätte es gedacht, damit kommen wir dann auch tatsächlich auch zum Ende dieser Sendung. Aber du hast aber noch jetzt noch mal so eine.
Wieso alle soll ich das verkünden oder die Dankesdinge mal lesen?
Nee, nee, Linus, Linus, Linus muss jetzt hier nochmal so einen länger.
Ich muss eine längere.
Hollywood, Abspann vorlesen.
Kann ich, aber ich kann denen erklären. Und zwar äh hatte ich ja, glaube ich, angemerkt, dass Kongress war
und ähm ein Kongress hat dazu geführt, dass ich nicht ganz so oft im Büro war und das hat dazu geführt, dass es da ein Mailstau gab, ein Post
paket Stau, der äh so groß war, dass er nicht in mein Postfach war und deswegen habe ich erst jetzt im Januar ähm
eine größere Menge Pakete gefunden
und ähm möchte daher jetzt eine etwas längere Dankesliste für wahrscheinlich äh Dezember und Januar machen
und äh deshalb danke ich in dieser Folge
in der Michi, dem Frank, der Miriam, dem Marco, dem Lui, dem Paul, dem Sebastian, dem
äh dem Bobo, dem Pepo,
Zebras, dem Mensch zwei null, der Stella, aber erst, wenn sie das Aquarell rausgerückt hat und dem Stefan Urbach, die mich äh zu Weihnachten äh beschenkt haben und da möchte ich freundlich danken
Weiterhin gilt natürlich dank dem Henrik, dem Michael, dem Franz, dem Moritz, dem Christian.
Frank. Oh Frank.
Dem Franz aber auch ähm dem Michael, dem Heiko, dem Ronny, dem Kostja, dem Ralf, dem Reiko, dem Christian,
und dem Hannes sowie natürlich Krake und Bense.
Und ich möchte noch alle grüßen, die mich kennen.
Und nicht nur die Oma oder so.
Die Oma auch auf jeden Fall.
Ja und viele andere mehr, die äh Unterstützung äh leisten auf vielfältigen äh Wegen. Ist immer so schwierig, wenn man irgendwie erstmal anfängt, mit irgendjemandem besser. Die Liste ist eigentlich endlos.
Ja, das ist auch immer, also es ist äh aber man tritt sich da natürlich das das Problem ein, dass man auf gar keinen Fall auch nur eine Person vergessen darf,
wie zum Beispiel die Christine, die ich jetzt hier in dieser Liste vergessen hatte, aber zum Glück nochmal mich dran erinnern konnte.
Ja, so, wir danken dann aber nochmal hier äh John Ev Niebel.
Danke auch für die Einladung.
Genau. Für den äh Beitrag. Ihr lest alle ab sofort Metronaut und hört laut. Metrolaut,
Und natürlich auch Logbuch, weil da geht's nächste Woche wieder weiter. Wir sind äh klar terminiert.
Ich will ja trotzdem mal echt eine App machen, dass ihr irgendwie auch mal vielleicht kriegen wir die auch zensiert.
Nur um zensiert zu werden. Möchtest du eine App machen?
Nur um zensiert zu werden, Tim, dafür musst du hart arbeiten.
Du meinst, wenn man irgendwie keine zensierte App hat, dann dann ist man nichts geworden in seinem Leben.
Kann man so jetzt auch nicht sagen, aber man ist auf jeden Fall schon mal mehr geworden, wenn man zensiert.
Man muss auch Verständnis haben für Apple. Ich habe auch schon, ich habe auch schon mal so eine App-Plattform betrieben. Und da musste ich mir auch über äh solche Sachen Gedanken machen.
Was für eine App-Plattform. Wen hast du zensiert? Ah und dann kam Penen. Was glaubst du? Blinkende Penen.
Was glaubst du, was du da was du dafür für eine Scheiße kriegst, so. Und da war also auf jeden Fall der App-Store, der Black Nights App Store, der hat auf jeden Fall auch ganz schön zu tun.
Ja, ja, da war da übernimmt man ja auch Verantwortung und so. Man musste schon.
Und was hast du so zensiert?
Das war halt äh ein Kunstwerk, da wusste sozusagen auch eine gewisse Qualitätssicherung äh sichergestellt werden.
Bei Kunst ist klar, da muss man erstmal aufpassen, dass die Qualität stimmt und die politische Linie. Klar, nee, leuchtet ein.
Ja, dann hatten wir noch dieses spezifische Problem, dass wir sozusagen, ja, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein etwas äh schwieriges Launes-Date äh hatten. Du weißt schon.
Elfter September zweitausendeins und ähm.
Er Flugzeuge wurden dann auch auf einmal zitiert. Äh zensiert.
Und so weiter. Da muss man dann schon auch nochmal sozusagen auch mal ein bisschen für die äh öffentliche Seele mitdenken und dann äh,
sozusagen bestimmte, bestimmte Inhalte zeitlich äh nach hinten geschoben, wo dann vielleicht der Humor dann besser mitge äh laufen ist so, ne. Also ist nicht immer ganz so einfach, ne.
Das war's, Leute. Wir grüßen euch. Bis bald.
Tschau, tschau. Tschau.
Ciao.